this linux course will teach you the
basics you need to know as a penetration
tester it was created by hackersploit
who has one of the most popular cyber
security channels on youtube hey guys
hackersploit here back again with
another video and welcome to the linux
essentials for hackers the 20 you need
to know and uh first of all let me
explain to you what this series is about
before we actually take a look at what
we'll be covering and the various issues
that uh you know uh
beginners in infosec
and ethical hacking usually face when
dealing with the topic of linux so uh it
comes as no surprise that linux is very
very important uh to learn if you are
going to get into infosec because uh you
will be
using various linux based uh offensive
distributions like kali linux or parrot
os and it's it's imperative that you
understand how to use the system to your
advantage how to become efficient at it
and that's primarily what this course is
focused on now if you are a system
administrator then it is uh worth also
going through this course because we'll
be covering a various aspects that you
might not have known about but again if
you're a beginner this is perfect for
you this will cover exactly what you
need to know to be efficient and
effective with linux uh when it comes
down to pen testing or ethical hacking
getting started is very simple if you
are a pen tester or you're a beginner to
linux uh you can install linux from
scratch or run it in a virtual machine i
prefer running you know installing it
from scratch on a physical machine
however if you are interested in you
know delving into the various
distributions that exist you can check
out distrowatch.com and you can start
playing around with them uh you know in
a vm
or you could opt to set up a linux
server all right so that's pretty much
all that i wanted to talk about in
regards to an introduction to this
course and without further ado let's get
cracking
in this video we're going to get started
with taking a look at the various
keyboard shortcuts that will help you
navigate around the system much easier
and work with the terminal at a much
more efficient rate all right so let's
get started now i'm currently using
ubuntu you can be using any other linux
distribution that you want
and we're going to be primarily working
with the terminal first before we
actually delve into desktop environments
uh and you know various other
distributions so we're going to be using
debian and again ubuntu is based off
debian and for our package manager we'll
be taking a look at the aptitude package
manager but as i said we'll be delving
into all of that later on all right so
with ubuntu uh getting opening up a
terminal with your keyboard is very
simple you have your control alt n t key
or you have your super and t if you're
running debian or any other distribution
so on ubuntu it's ctrl alt n t
or your super nt and you can customize
your keyboard shortcuts uh however you
want all right so
let me just uh let me just minimize this
now uh the other interesting thing that
you can do or very helpful thing that
you can do when working with various
windows it doesn't have to be a
a terminal window is you can perform
tiling and that is by using the super
key and your arrow keys to direct the
location of the windows and you can tile
them appropriately right so as you can
see i've used the super and up key and
that maximizes it and of course i can
take it to the left or i can take it to
the right and i can you know leave it
where where it was previously right so
let me just expand it now let me talk
about a font size right so font size is
very easy to change and to actually
increase and reduce so if i wanted to
increase my font size i would use the
control shift and the plus key on my
keyboard and that would increase the
font size right
i can then minimize it by using the
control and the minus key on my keyboard
and that will reduce the font size so
again increasing it is ctrl shift and
and the plus key
and reducing the font size is control
and the minus key on your keyboard right
so
that is how to increase and reduce your
font size now let's talk about
actually clearing your screen which is
very very simple so i'll just use a
generic command here you don't have to
worry about what that command is so if i
wanted to clear my terminal i would
simply say clear and that will get rid
of all the content that was currently on
the terminal however
i can also use a keyboard
keyboard shortcut so again if i just
list the same command here i can use the
control and l key and that will clear
the terminal for me without me having to
type the clear command all right so
let's talk about some uh some other
keyboard shortcuts that you should be
aware of right so uh if we are working
with a particular process so for example
i can say
nmap i can run a quick nmap scan here
and i can just say sv
192.168.1.1
and we can hit enter i can use the
control c key
to actually end the currently running
process and it will return you back to
your uh to your shell uh in this case
we're using the bash shell so if i want
to end a process that's currently
running like the one i was running which
was nmap i use the control and c
keyboard shortcut right now if i wanted
to suspend or to pause this
or to pause a particular task or a
process i can use the control and z key
right so if i was running nmap s v the
same key or the same command i can type
that out however here are other useful
keyboard shortcuts that you can use so i
can cycle through my previously used
commands by using the up arrow key and
that will again cycle through all my all
my previously used commands so again i
can just go to this previous command and
hit enter and then i can use ctrl and z
to actually uh pause and suspend that
process uh in memory and remember it
hasn't stopped it you have just
suspended it all right now let's talk
about tab uh
let's talk about the tab key and auto
completion right so uh we can use the
tab key uh to auto complete file and
directory names so let me just clear
this out and i can use the control and l
key so if i go to my uh well i can
actually work from my home directory but
let's say i wanted to cat a particular
file so let me just list all the files
in here so let's say i wanted to cat my
let's see or let's say i wanted to get
my my password file so again i can say
cat
etsy
and i can say password right now
if i wanted to auto complete this i
could use the tab key and again it'll if
i use it two times it will give me the
various suggestions here so a single tab
will auto complete it if it has an
accurate uh id of of the particular file
or directory you're referring to so
again if i said uh if i give it a bit
more information in regards to the file
or directory i was looking for i would
simply just hit tab and it gives me the
file there however i can hit double tab
and that again gives me the files that
are related to the particular data that
have entered here so again if i reduced
it just to ap and i hit tab twice it
will give us the recommendations as to
uh in in reference to the to to the
to the particular files that uh that
begin with the word p and again if i can
increase that uh probability or the
specification of the file i'm looking
i'm looking for by increasing the amount
of letters so again
again i can tap it twice and now you can
see the results are more fine-tuned so
again i can
i can use tab to auto complete it to
password and i can hit enter and that
displays the contents of the password
file so that is how to use uh the tab
key and those are the various uh you
know commands that uh or keyboard
shortcuts that you can use while working
in the terminal and hopefully those will
make your life a whole lot easier so
again control and l that clears
everything for me
now let's talk about how to close your
terminal so again closing your terminal
is very simple you can use the control
shift and w key so again i can say
control shift and w here
right over here and that works pretty
universally among all distributions so
again control alt d that opens up your
terminal uh increasing the font size
control shift and the plus key and so on
and so forth and you can tile your
terminal or any window in your system by
using the super key and your arrow keys
or your directional keys here
all right so those are all uh the basic
keyboard shortcuts that i wanted to
start off with i'll be referencing
others throughout the series uh let me
know which ones are i missed and i'll be
seeing you in the next video in this
series
in this video we're going to be taking a
look at file management and file
manipulation uh in linux so let's get
started so i'm just going to open up my
terminal here and let's just expand this
and let's increase the font size so we
can see what's going on all right so
let's start off with a bit of directory
navigation and understanding uh what
files exist within a directory right so
the first question any beginner to linux
has is when the in the terminal is how
do i know where i am or how do i know
what directory i'm in right so they want
to know where where they actually exist
in the linux file system so by default
if you are logged in as a user uh you
know that a user is not the root user uh
so you know a normal user account for
example i'm logged in as a lexis
so i'm going to be in my current home
directory now you can confirm this by
typing in pwd all right pwd means print
current working directory or print
working directory and that is
self-explanatory it prints the current
directory that you are in and that you
uh will be working in or any commands
that you actually run will be executed
within this directory right so i'm going
to hit enter
and as you can see it tells you i'm in
the home alexis directory now user
accounts are usually sorted out this way
so the root account usually has its own
folder in the root directory
of the file system of the linux file
system whereas other users like alexis
here
will be found within the home directory
and then furthermore their own
individual directories based on their
usernames and this is where all their
files will be stored all right which
brings us to the next question which is
how do i list the files within a
particular directory and this is very
simple we use the ls command which means
list all right so i'm going to hit enter
and this will list the files and the
directories within the current directory
right so i'm going to enter and as you
can see it tells us within this current
directory we we have the desktop
directory uh the documents directory
downloads etc etc right so
this is the simple way of listing files
now the ls command has the ability to be
run with other arguments or commands or
options that allow you to increase or to
modify the way the output is
or the way the files are displayed to
you right so a quick example of this is
by using the ls hyphen or dash l command
all right so this will list all the
files and directories in this directory
uh in the format of a list or a table
which makes it easier to read for users
right so i'm going to hit enter and
immediately you can see it gives you a
vital information like the total
right of here the permissions the owner
the ownership of these files and
directories
you have the date modified and the name
of the file uh of the files and
directories
all right so
that is how to use ls in combination
with another command now you can also
get more output by combining the ls
command with other options so again if
we wanted to list all the files that are
all the files and directories that are
currently in this working directory i
can use the a command which essentially
is an abbreviation for all now when i
say all in the context of a linux it
means all hidden files all files within
this directory will be displayed all
right so if i list the files again here
you can see that it only displays the
the files and directories that are
visible to users if we want to display
all the files and directories including
hidden files and directories we can say
ls and we can say a
all right and this again will give us
all files and directories including
hidden files and directory so you can
see the hidden files in linux have the
dot or the full stop
before the file name here so again the
bash aliases file is a file that is used
in configuration of your bash profile so
again it allows you to configure aliases
when working with bash again so the
hidden files in nx typically are used
for configuration of various system uh
system environment variables or various
system tools uh you know so on and so
forth we'll be working with this later
on and it will all make sense shortly
now the great thing about the list
command is that i can use it in
combination with the previous command so
if i wanted to list this in a way that
was much easier to read i can say ls a l
and this will list all the files and
directories including the hidden files
and directories in the format of a list
or a table and i hit enter and there you
are you can see
it displays all the files and
directories in the form of a list here
and again it gives you information in
regards to the ownership and the
permissions more of which we'll touch
upon later on in the course all right so
i'm just going to clear the terminal
here and let's take a look at the ls
command a little bit more all right so
let's say i wanted to um to actually
list the files um in a more
readable format for users so again i can
just type in ls
l and i can use the h command all right
so if i hit enter again this displays it
in a much easier way for uh for users to
understand what's going on and the
context i'm referring to is more to do
with the size all right so if i say ls l
you can see that the data here or the
size of the files is in bytes right now
when we use the ls h or the h where the
h stands for human readable format you
can see it displays the actual size in
kilobytes a much easier way for you to
understand the sizes of files
etc etc all right so let me just clear
the terminal here
and
let's take a look at one more uh command
that we can use with ls and that is if
we wanted to uh show uh subdirectories
right so remember when we show when we
use the ls command
it shows us the directories within this
current working directory but let's say
we had other directories within um let's
see
within pictures right so we could have
other directories within pictures or
documents or the downloads folder etc so
again we can say
uh if i wanted to list
the the the subdirectories within the
desktop folder i can say
ls
l and we'll use the capital r command
and this again means recursively so we
can then specify the folder we want
which is going to be desktop or the
directory we want again it's going to be
desktop and we hit enter and again it
will list for us the files that exist on
the desktop first of all and again it
shows us that we have
a directory called c
and a txt file called todo.txt
all right within the c folder or the c
directory we have three files we have a
temp dot c
we have a test binary and a test.c file
so again it's displayed to us what is on
the desktop and then what is uh what is
in the directory c on the desktop so
again it's used for recursive a listing
of the of files and directories and sub
directories that way all right so i hope
that makes sense now let's talk about uh
some directory navigation all right
which is quite important here
uh before we actually talk about uh file
manipulation um and copying files etc so
as i said we are currently in the home
alexis directory now if i wanted to move
a step back or to move to a parent
directory i can say cp all right so cd
will change directory to the actual home
directory uh so again if i type in pwd
you can see it will not do anything now
if i wanted to go a step back i can type
in cd
and i can follow that or yes i can
follow that up with two full stops and
that will take me a step back and
immediately on your bash shell you'll be
given the current directory that you're
in now so again it's telling us we are
in the home directory and we can confirm
this by typing in pwd right so if we
list the files within the home directory
you can see that the only directory that
exists is the alexis folder and that's
because that's the only use on the
system so let's take a step back right
so i can take a step back and i hit
enter and now we are currently in the
root directory the root file system
directory for the off for linux right so
again i can list all the files in here
and i can hit enter and as you can see
we are now in the root this is the
actual root directory of the linux file
system not the root folder or the root
user directory just the root
of the file system so
you can now see all the various folders
that the linux file system is comprised
of all right so that is how to actually
navigate a step back now if i wanted to
navigate into any one of these
directories i could say cd and then i
specify cd is an abbreviation for change
directory and i can specify the
directory i want to move into so i can
say cd home
right and again that will take me into
my home directory and then i can list
the files in here and this tells me oh
we have a directory called alexisd
and then i can say change directory into
the directory alexis and that will take
me into the uh the directory alexis
all right now i can also use um i can
also use the forward slash to refer to a
directory that is currently not in this
particular directory so let's say i
wanted to move into the um let's see
i wanted to move into the
um let's try the etsy folder i can say
cd
forward slash etsy and this refers to a
directory that is currently not in this
directory but at the root at the root of
the linux file system so i hit enter and
that takes us into the etsy folder so
again i can confirm this by typing in
pwd and again it tells me i'm currently
in the etsy folder
right now if i want to navigate back to
my user home directory so i'm currently
logged in as the user alexis if i want
to go back to alexis home directory i
can simply do this by typing
home alexis right that's very very
simple but if i want to even make this
shorter i can use
the command right over here and again i
can hit enter
and
i can
easily just navigate back to my home
directory so if i hit enter you see and
i type in pwd it's going to take me into
my home directory right over here all
right now that we have taken a look at
you know directory navigation and moving
around directories let's take a look at
uh creating files copying etc all right
so i'm currently on my in my home
directory so let's talk about
actually copying a file
now before we actually do that we need
to actually understand how to create
files really really quickly right so
the first thing i want to do is i'll go
into my desktop here and i'll say cd
desktop and i'm going to hit enter and
i'm in my desktop now all right so if i
wanted to create a file really easily i
can use touch all right so touch is a
is a tool or a utility that allows you
to you know easily create files again
let me show you a command that will help
you understand what various commands and
tools are so if i want to know uh
i want information about a particular
command i can use the what is
the what is command so i can type in
what is and then i can say what is touch
and i can hit enter and again it tells
me change the file timestamps all right
or so i can also say what is
uh let's see what is nano right nano is
a text editor so i can hit enter and
it's going to tell nano is another
editor etc so it gives you information
about a particular command or tool all
right so i can use touch to create a
file remember without any content right
so i can say touch
and i can say the file name is going to
be test.txt
all right i can hit enter and if i list
all the files in the desktop you can see
i have the test.txt file right over here
all right so
i can now
direct data into this file so again i
can use the ech command and if we want
to learn more about the echo command i
can type in what is and i can say echo
and i can hit enter and it's going to
say display a line of text right so we
can say echo
alexis is
alexis is
you can say alexis is not cool i know
something like that
and i can just hit enter and again it
will display on our terminal alexis is
not cool all right so it simply just
displays a line of text however we can
redirect this data into a particular
file and in this case we want to dis we
want to redirect this data into the
test.txt file right so i can say echo
we can say hello
and we'll just use this simple string of
text here and i can say
redirect to this and we use the greater
than sign to redirect data to a
particular file or to a particular
command so i can say test dot txt all
right and i hit enter and now this file
should have the words or the string
hello now if you want to easily just
display the context uh or the content of
a file i can use the cat command all
right now again we can use the what is
command to find uh to find out more
about what the
cat command does so i can hit enter and
it's going to tell us it concatenates
files and prints on the standard output
so again it gives us the output of all
the content it prints out the content of
a particular file uh so again i can say
cat test dot txt and hit enter and again
it prints out what we had redirected
into it
all right so that is how to use the cat
command now again i can redirect a lot
of text into this uh so let's say i
wanted to edit this uh this file or i
wanted to remove this file which is a
much better way of actually taking a
look at you know file manipulation
technique so again i've shown you how to
create a file a very simple file
redirecting output
we can also
use cat to redirect output so for
example if i wanted to redirect the
contents of the password file i can say
cat hc password and i'm using the
relative directory you can see here so
the the the contents of the password
file i want to redirect into the
test.txt file however if i wanted to
create another file i could easily do it
directly from here i could say password
dot txt and i hit enter and now we can
display the contents of the password.txt
file and again i can use the tab
autocompletion here and i hit enter and
again it gives us all the content was
redirected into this new txt file
excellent so now let's talk about
actually you know create removing files
copying them etc so if i wanted to
remove this file here the test.txt file
i use the rm command which stands for
remove right again you can use the what
is command and again use it again it
tells you this is used to remove files
and directories so let's talk about
removing files first
all right so we can say remove uh test
dot txt all right and again we use tab
auto completion and i hit enter and this
will have removed the file over here
right so um
that is essentially how to remove a file
now
uh if i want to remove a directory uh i
can now i need to specify that it is a
recursive action but before we do that
let's talk about creating a directory
first because that that's quite
important as well so if i want to create
a directory i use the make directory
command which is abbreviated into mkdir
so make a directory and i give it a name
so i can say test all right so this is
going to create a folder or id or a
directory called test
right once i hit enter and i list all
the files here you can see we have the
test directory over here uh so what i
can do is
i can you know i can navigate into it i
can copy files into it so let's say i
wanted to copy a file into this uh
directory so again i can say
let's say i wanted to say touch um or we
can do the same thing so i can say cat
etsy
password and i want to redirect this
into a file called
password.txt and once that is done i
want to copy the file so i want to say
cp that means copy and i want to specify
the file that i want to copy which is
going to be password dot txt and i want
to copy that into the test directory so
i specify the directory i want to copy
in i want to copy it into
in this case the test directory is
within the current working directory so
i don't have to specify a relative path
if i was specifying a relative path i
would use the forward slash here so i
can just say test
and i hit enter and now if i remember if
i wanted to list the contents of the sub
directories recursively i could say ls
lr and i hit enter and you can see the
contents of the test directory uh
password.txt
excellent so again if i want to remove
the the password file i can say
removepassword.txt
if i want to remove a directory and the
directory what we want to remove is the
test directory i can say remove and i
use the capital r which means
recursively remove and i say test and i
use the tab autocompletion and i hit
enter and now if we list the files in
the on the desktop you can see we've
gotten rid of all of these folders and
files
all right so
now that we know how to actually create
a directory we can actually um
let me talk about removing a directory i
actually covered it with the remove
command however we can also use um
another command called remove directory
which is abbreviated into rmdir
this will only allow you to remove a
directory if you do not have any files
within that directory right so let's say
i uh
by the way you can cycle through your
previously used commands using your
arrow keys in this case you can use the
uh the up arrow key so let's say i
wanted to catch i wanted to you know
redirect output of the password file
into a file called password.txt and i
wanted to copy this file or let's
actually talk about
moving files so if i wanted to move a
file i would say mv and again you can
use the what is command so what is mv
so i can say mv i want to move the
password txt file into the test
directory here i'm going to hit enter
and now you can see that the
the password file has been moved into
the test directory so again i can
i can list all the files within the test
directory here and that again it tells
me that we only have the password.txt
file in here so if i use the rm dir
command which means remove directory and
i say test remove directory test you can
see it's going to tell me that this
directory is not empty so as a result we
need to specify remove
recursively
test and we're going to hit enter and
now it gets rid of the test directory
for us all right so those are uh very
very simple ways of
you know creating copying and of of
course deleting commands now uh
before we actually end this video which
i know has been going on for quite a
while i'm going to be covering file
directory permissions later but i want
to talk
i want to talk about file manipulation a
little bit more uh so we've talked about
uh you know using the cat command
redirecting output uh using touch as
well moving files let's talk about you
know renaming files
uh and also taking a look at the content
of particular files here so what i want
to do now is
let's actually take a look at um
at actually renaming files all right so
i'm going to again use the similar
command that we had used i'm just going
to you know
i'm going to redirect the output of the
password file into a file called
password.txt
and now if i wanted to rename the
filepassword.txt
into something else i would use the mv
command right so there isn't a command
to rename files in linux you use the mv
command which means move
in this case it's very simple the syntax
is uh you specify the file that you want
to change the name of which is going to
be password.txt and i changed the file
name to let's say
test
dot txt
and hit enter and now if we list all the
files in the directory you can see that
it changes it to test.txt and indeed if
we actually uh if we actually
display the contents of the file you can
see that the the content is preserved
while we've changed the name and we can
also change the extension of the file so
i could say move
test.txt into test
let's say test.c we can we can change
the contents into a c file right and now
if i say uh cat test dot c
i can hit enter and there you are now
let's talk about uh editors and then
i'll talk about the content of the files
uh before we actually end this video so
um
there are two uh standard editors that
are pretty much the standard when it
comes to linux and working within the
terminal i'm not talking about graphical
uh gui based editors like uh g edit and
stuff so if i wanted to edit this file
within the terminal i have two options i
have nano so again i can use the what is
command and say what is nano and again
that's an editor and i have we have vim
which is pretty much the most popular
option and i'll be making independent
videos on this editors and how to
configure them so again if i want to
edit the test.txt file i can say nano
test.tx
test.c
let's actually rename it back to
test.txt
dot txt and we say nano test
dot txt and we're hit enter and that
takes us into nano now exiting nano is
very simple again you can navigate
around make changes uh exiting it we use
control and x and that's it now with v
vim or vi we simply type in vi or vim
and we say test.txt hit enter and again
with them the syntax is very different
if i want to make changes or i want to
add content i type in i to insert text
and again i can play around with it and
once i'm done i hit escape and then i
can write changes to this file or i can
quit and discard any changes by typing
in q
and the exclamation mark and hit enter
and that's how to use the various
editors i'm not covering them uh you
know to their full to their fullest
extent and that's because we have
various videos that will be actually
focused on editors themselves so um
that's pretty much all that i wanted to
cover in this video there's quite a bit
hopefully you guys can actually learn a
lot from this video
in this video we're going to be talking
about file and directory permissions and
ownership all right so again there's
quite a bit to cover and hopefully i'll
explain the various ways of doing it and
i hopefully i can explain it as best as
i can all right so let me just open up a
terminal here and we can get started
immediately right so
let's just expand this and there we are
all right so the first thing i'm going
to do is i'm just going to go on to my
desktop or change my directory onto my
desktop and i'm just going to clear this
now one thing i want to talk about
before i actually get started if i list
all the files in here you can see that
directories will typically be
highlighted in blue and to keep this on
a standardized basis you want the color
scheme for your terminal to be the linux
console or you can use xterm if you want
and again that will just keep it really
standardized but for the purpose of this
video i'm just going to stick to the
linux console again just so directories
and
your directories are highlighted blue
and again executable files are
highlighted green all right so that'll
keep things uh more simple and very easy
to understand all right so let's get
started so again if i list all the files
in this directory uh you can see that um
typically when i list it in the form of
a list or a table we have various bits
of information right so again i can also
you know
type this in and print it out print it
out in human readable format but again
that doesn't explain
a lot of the information that already is
here all right so we have the first
column which is your file permissions
file and directory permissions um you
then have the user and the group all
right so this is to do with ownership
these two are to do with ownership you
then have the file size uh and the date
modified and of course you have the the
file or the directory name
as is
as as is and as was created all right so
what i'm going to do is the first thing
i want to do is i'm just going to create
a simple file i'm just going to call it
test
test dot sh because i know many of you
don't like me sticking with one type of
file
and what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to cut the contents of the
password file
into the test dot sh file right
and i can just hit enter and we can
clear this out and let me also create a
directory here and we'll just call it
test and let's clear this out all right
so now if i list all the files here
you can see that
we have the new files that we just
created test.sh and the test directory
so
if we take a look at the permissions for
the sh file which is a shell file and is
potentially executable however in this
current state it isn't and you might be
asking well why isn't it executable and
that's where file and directory
permissions come into play now
permissions in linux are very very
simple to understand now many people
usually you know complicate it quite a
bit and there isn't a need for this uh
again there are two ways of handling it
which is where most of the confusion
starts that is the symbolic mode format
and the uh the octal mode or the binary
mode as it's so referred to as all right
and these basically deal with various
techniques as to which you can ascertain
or set
uh you know their various permissions
for files and directories but the first
thing you need to understand first of
all if you're a beginner is there three
types of permissions that you can apply
to a file or directory in linux those
are read which is represented by r as
you can see right over here uh the the
second one is the w or the right
permissions and the last one is the x
permission which stands for executable
so these basically mean read this allows
this means that you're allowed to read
the file uh the right permission means
you're allowed to write changes to the
file and the x permission means you're
allowed to execute the file now you
might be saying well we have various uh
various
sequences of these permissions appearing
here how is it sorted out and that's a
very good question so let's take a
simple example of the test.sh file right
over here all right so first of all uh
as you'll see right over here each of
these is sorted into
six uh into six columns however they're
really not separated but that's how you
have to understand them so you have your
first one here you have your second one
here and you have your third one here
now this initial prefix here is
is there to tell you the type of file
you're dealing with in this case we're
dealing with a file so it leaves that
blank in the case of if of a directory
it will be annotated by a d and that
tells you that you're dealing with a
directory all right so let's let's talk
about the other columns here so the
first uh the first one here is for the
owner of the file alright so these are
the owner permissions now when we're
talking about ownership for this
particular file we can see that the
owner of the file and the group that it
belongs to
is alexis all right now if it belonged
to another user that means that these
permissions were specific to that
particular user or the owner of the file
the second column here is in uh these
are the permissions for the group all
right so again these are group
permissions and the last one are for all
other users on the system so let's say i
created a file and i'm currently in the
alexis uh the home alexis desktop
directory here
uh let's say i was logged in as another
user and i navigated into this directory
and i tried to execute this file over
here well given that i would be i was
using another user
the permissions for this file
explicitly state that i can read the
file however i cannot execute it or i
cannot write any particular changes to
it so hopefully that makes sense now
let's talk about changing these
permissions or setting these permissions
for these files now this is where the
chmod command comes into place all right
so the chmod commands allows you to
change the mode for files and
directories and allows you to change
permissions for the file and directories
so again i can say i can use the what is
command with chmod and you can see it
allows you to change the file mode bits
and change the permissions of a file or
directory right quite simple
now let's talk about this for a second
it's very easy to use we say chmod
and then we specify the options that we
want and finally after the options we
specify the file to which we want to
apply these permissions to all right so
very very simple syntax however as i
mentioned there are two ways of doing
this many people are comfortable with
their own way and i recommend that you
find your own way of going about this
but i will make a recommendation to make
things a whole lot easier and maybe uh
one way that you can understand it you
know a whole lot better all right so
that the the first way is by using the
symbolic mode format all right and the
second way is by using the octal
or the binary mode all right so let's
start off with the symbolic mode format
all right so let's say i wanted to
change the permissions
for the file
the file test dot sh right over here all
right so you can see that we we
currently cannot execute it so uh what
i'm going to do is let me just remove or
i can just
what i can do is just
get etsy or we can just say dev null and
don't worry what i'm doing here i just
want to
dot sh and we can actually just say echo
um we can say
echo hello world and we can just use
this and we can pipe that into the file
test.sh and now if we try and execute
this file
you can see that we hit enter we can see
that we do not have the particular or
the necessary permissions to execute
this so that will be our goal here our
goal is to set uh or to provide uh the
user lexis with executable permissions
all right so let me just list this one
more time and we can take a look at the
permission so for the owner alexis he
can only read and write changes to the
file which we we pretty much did already
uh for the group they can only read the
file uh and for all other users they can
only read it all right so let's talk
about the symbolic mode format
so the symbolic mode format is very
simple to understand of course i've
mentioned it has to do with the various
permissions so read write and execute
and it is done in conjunction with the
chmod command all right so now with the
chmod command i can now specify
the specification in regards to the
uh to the user the group uh
the uh the other or for all users all
right so what this means is
if i wanted to specify permissions or
set permissions for uh for the current
user i would do that by typing in chmod
u
and then i can add permissions i can say
you um i can say i can add permissions
by using the plus sign or i can say u is
equal to and then i would set the
permission so i can say user
the current user is going to be
read write and execute
we're going to provide this user with
the read write and execute permissions
and then we specify the file that we
want to apply these permissions to so i
can say test dot sh all right and i can
hit enter now if i list all the files
here again you can now see that the the
user alexis or the owner alexis has read
write an executable permissions which
means we can now execute this file and
we just entered a simple piece of uh
code here so again we can say test.sh
and again we we cannot we can actually
just modify this sorry uh we can say
just going to test.sh and we can just
say
echo
so that whenever we print it out we can
actually get those
this little string of text here again so
let me just write and exit there and you
can see that that was successful so
again if we execute the file here you
can see it prints out the string hello
world excellent so now we have set the
permissions for the user using the
symbolic mode format all right so we can
also remove permissions
uh and again i've shown you how to
explicitly set the permission so again
let's go over that one more second one
more time so chmod and now let's say we
wanted to apply uh these same
permissions for all the users on the
system all right and for for for for the
group all right so to do this we use the
group
uh and the o sign uh or we can also use
the a sign all right
and that will mean a group and all other
users on the system so group and all of
these users on the system so again the
standard definition is
for use the current user or the owner of
the file g is for the group uh and again
o is for other and a is for all all
right so that will set for all so we can
say group and we can then say group and
other
uh is will have read write and
executable permissions and then we
specify the file here and we hit enter
and then that will set the permissions
explicitly so again if we list all the
files now you can see that the the the
current user uh the group and all other
users have read write and executable
permissions which means i can now
execute this file if i was logged in as
another user that belongs to any other
group on the system which is not
recommended so let's talk about how to
remove these permissions all right so i
can say chmod
and let's say i wanted to remove the uh
the right and executable permissions for
for the groups and other users on the
system so again we say go and now we say
minus
wx so the right and executable
permissions and we say test dot sh and
we hit enter and now if we list all the
files here you can see that now we have
removed all these permissions so the
only the current user is only allowed to
read write and execute the file however
the group and the other users on the
system are only able to read it so that
is essentially how to use the symbolic
mode format so you can see it's a very
simple system to use let me just go over
it one more time we use the chmod
command we then specify the user uh the
group
uh other
uh other or all all right so again ugo a
that is the standard uh
the standard definition there and then
of course we use the plus or the equal
signs to add permissions or to
explicitly set them so for example if i
wanted to give the group execute
executable permissions i would say chmod
group plus x all right so we're setting
it for the group and we're giving it
executable permissions we then specify
the file
and we hit enter and now if we list all
the files here you can see that it gives
the group executable permissions so it
can read the file and execute it however
it cannot it cannot write changes to the
file so i can i can also get rid of it
so again chmod minus we can say group
minus x
uh so remove the executable permissions
and then we specify the file we hit
enter and again if we list the files
here you can see we're back to the old
uh permission so again a very simple way
of setting permissions
all right now let's talk about uh the
binary or the octal mode of setting
permissions
all right so now let's talk about the
octal or the binary mode of setting
permissions right which is again very
simple and is my preferred way of
actually going about doing it now again
as i said it's entirely up to you all
right so again we are still using the
chmod operator here and again this is
the standard so again we can say chmod
and then now when dealing with the
binary or the octal mode of setting
permissions
the read write and executable
permissions are now denoted in a binary
format and you might be saying well if
that's the case doesn't that make it a
little bit complex well i'll explain why
it it will not make it complex all right
so let me explain something so typically
as i said the read uh right and
executable permissions are now
represented by a binary value all right
so the read value is
the the read permission is represented
by a value of four all right the right
permission
is execute is uh is denoted or
represented by a value of two sorry and
the executable permission is represented
by a value of one all right and again
we're still following the previous uh
the previous format of going of actually
uh understanding permissions here so
again we have the uh the owner now the
owner of the file or the directory uh
you then have the group and others uh
other users on the system
all right so let's work with the test.sh
file and i'll talk about setting
directory permissions which is again
very very simple as well
all right so
let's say we wanted to get rid of the
the write and execute permissions for
the owner of the file which is right
over here you can see it has read write
and execute permissions so to do this
with the the binary mode or the octal
mode
again we need to specify chmod and now
the permissions if you already know
about this are now represented by the by
binary values all right so as i said for
the owner
we want to actually specify the
following so again we can say
chmod
and for the owner we need to specify the
we want to get rid of the right and
executable permissions so we only have
the
the write permission which again as we
said is going to have a value
of four all right so we start off with
the value of four so we're going to say
chmod four
and then for the other files uh uh also
for the other for the group and for the
other uh users on the system we want to
use the same permission we so we're
gonna say chmod four 444
and then we specify the file name
test.sh and we hit enter and now if we
list the files in here you can see that
now the file
only has read permissions
for the owner the group and other users
on the system all right so that's how to
set it now if i wanted to give the um
the owner of the file read write and
execute permissions we would need to add
these binary values together all right
so read is going to be equal to four all
right right is going to be equal to two
and um
and execute is going to be equal to one
all right so two plus four
is going to be six six plus one is going
to be 7. so we say chmod 7 that is for
the user permissions or the owner
permission so read write and execute
let's say for the group and the other
users on the system we want to give them
only read permissions which again is
denoted by four so that's four uh read
permissions for the group
and for other users on the system the
same thing and then we type in the name
of the file all right and i'm gonna hit
enter
and we can now display this and
immediately you can see we now have read
write and executable permissions for the
owner for for the group we only have
read permissions and for other users on
the system we only have read permissions
all right so that's very easy to
understand now if it is complex i will
leave a uh a resource in the description
section that has a table of all of these
permissions but the math is very simple
right so again we're simply adding 4
plus
plus 2 plus 1 and that is for all
permissions so this is
right
so again this is
sorry this is read write
and this is execute so 4 plus 2 plus 1
is going to be 7. if i only want read
permissions it's going to be four if i
only want
read and write permissions it's going to
be six again that would be uh seven six
six or if i only wanted um
read
uh and execute permissions that would be
uh so for example if we wanted for the
user or the owner read write and execute
permissions that would be seven and then
for the group and for all of the users
we only wanted read and execute
permissions that would be seven five
five all right so it's very easy to set
permissions this way and again you're
always setting explicitly for the user
uh for for the owner the the the user
the group and then all the other users
on the system so that's something you
need to take
into consideration all right so now
let's move on to actually uh changing
you know directory permissions all right
so if i list all the files here again
you can use the symbolic mode or the uh
the octal mode whatever is comfortable
with you we have the test directory that
we created so again if we wanted to
provide it with all permissions you can
see that it has read write permissions
for the current user and for the group
and the other users it only has read
permission so again we can say chmod
uh user we if we use the symbolic mode
we can say user
uh user group and other that's going to
be equal to read write and execute and
then we say test the name of the
directory and we hit enter and now if we
list all the files in here you can see
that the permissions have been set
uh and then again if we wanted to go
back i can say chmod
and let's say we only wanted the file to
be re we only wanted the user to be able
to read and
write to this particular directory then
we would say this is going to be equal
to 4 plus 2 is going to be 6
4 4 and then we say test and we hit
enter we again we can just confirm the
permissions have been changed and there
you are so that's how to set uh
permissions on a directory however if
there are other directories and files
within this directory then we need to
set these permissions we can set them
recursively and to do this we can then
type in chmod
and if we use the r command the capital
r command that means recursive
permissions so again we can then say uh
before we do that let's actually move
this file the test file the test.sh file
into the test directory
and you can see it it tells us that we
do not have adequate permissions and
that's because again if we list all the
if we list all the permissions here for
the the directory
uh if we say for example uh for this
particular file
let's say we want to say chmod 755 test
dot sh and now we say move uh test dot
sh into the test directory and we hit
enter that is telling us that we cannot
move it nuts primarily because of the
the the permissions for the directory so
we can say chmod 755 a test and we hit
enter and then we can say move
we can then say test.sh into the test
folder here and we hit enter and now we
can move it all right so that proves
again that the importance of permissions
and understanding them so now if we
check the directory test uh the the
files within the directory test we have
the test.sh file so now if we wanted to
to actually provide this directory and
all the files within it files and
directories within it recursively with
all permissions i could say chmod
777 and that gives it read write and
executable permissions for the the owner
uh the group and all other users on the
system so again i would say chmod
recursively 777 and i'm using the octal
mode as you would have guessed and then
we specify the directory and hit enter
and now if we list all uh the directory
itself you can see it has all
permissions if we list uh all the files
uh within the the test directory if we
list the permissions here you can see
that the test.sh file now has all has
also uh those permissions and they have
been applied recursively so if i had any
other files or directories within this
directory uh they would have been
applied as well all right so now that we
have actually uh taken a look at file
ownership uh sorry file permissions
let's take a look at file ownership
in this video we're going to be talking
about file ownership which is a fairly
simple topic to understand and again in
the previous video we used the chmod
operator
or the chmod tool and in this video
we're going to be using the ch own tool
again which is quite self-explanatory it
allows us to change the ownership of
files and directories which is quite
important all right so as we did in the
previous video
you can see that we were able to
change the permissions for this for the
test directory and the test files within
it and i've just changed them back to
some pretty standard uh uh to some
pretty standard permissions here and
again uh we also had the
we also had the uh the test.sh file
within the test directory so
let's talk about ownership so as i
mentioned the current owner of this file
right over here is alexis and this is
the this is denoted uh right over here
so the ownership information and the
group ownership information if there is
any
now as i said uh we we haven't talked
about adding users and groups which is
fairly simple we haven't talked about
you know setting particular permissions
for users uh you know uh within the uh
the sudo as file but that's something
we'll get to later
so if we wanted to change the ownership
of this file
to
uh
to to let's say the root user i can do
that very very easily so again i can say
let me just go into the the root user
here and now i'm currently logged in as
the root user so if i wanted to change
the ownership and i'll go into the test
directory if i wanted to change the
ownership of the test.sh file
what i can do now is i can say ch own
and again you can use the what is tool
or the what is utility to actually give
you some more information about the the
ch own tool so again it tells you this
allows you to change your file owner and
group and of course change the ownership
of a file
all right so now if i wanted to change
the ownership of the test.sh file
from alexis to to the root user i can do
this very very easily so i can say
i can say ch own
and then i specify the the the user i
want to uh to actually change the
ownership to in this case to the root
user and then i'll specify the file name
which is going to be test.sh and i hit
enter and now if i list all the files
here you can see that the owner of the
file has been changed to root however
the group of this file is still alexis
all right so that's something that we
also have to change to change the group
or to change the group order here
it's very simple we use the change group
command which again is denoted by
uh it is denoted by change grp so chgrp
and again we can use the what is tool
change drp hit enter and this allows you
to change group ownership so let's say
we want to change the group ownership to
root as well or to the root group
if we type in groups and we say root
again that tells us what
what group the root user belongs to and
as you can see it belongs to the root uh
due to the root group uh and again we
can say groups alexis and uh you can see
these are the groups that the user lexis
belongs to it belongs to the to the
group alexis adm cd rom sudo etc etc
all right so let's say i wanted to
change the group of this file so change
group
um
and then i say change it to the group
root
and i want you to change the file
test.sh and now if we list the
permissions here or the ownership sorry
um
we can see now that the owner of the
file is the root user
and the the group ownership of this file
belongs to the to to to the group uh two
to the root group right over here all
right so that is how to use the ch own
and the ch
group or the change group command to
change the ownership of a file now again
we haven't experimented with users yet
and that's something we'll be touching
upon quite soon so we'll be explaining
this as we move along
in this video we're going to be talking
about how to use the grep tool in
regards to looking for data or
information in files all right so this
is one of the most important linux
utilities or tools that uh you can you
can learn how to use and it will really
improve your efficiency when dealing
with data and working in the terminal
okay so let's actually get started with
understanding what it is and what it
does all right so the first thing we can
do is we can just use the waters command
to give us a bit of a context or
information in in regards to what this
tool is and what it does so again it
tells you
this prints lines matching a particular
pattern and again if you're interested
in learning more about the tool you can
always use the manual pages or go
through the manual pages for the
particular tool so there you are it
gives you information or in regards to
how to use it the purpose of this video
is to show you how to use it in the most
efficient way or in a way to therefore
in increase your understanding on on how
to use the tool
and how to make you efficient with using
it
all right so uh before we we actually
take a look at a concrete example of how
to use grep
we must understand two things all right
the first thing you need to understand
is there are two ways of using grip the
first way is by using grip on its own
all right so again we can just type in
grep here
uh and the other way of using grip is by
actually piping the output of another
command into grep and then finding what
you're looking for all right so you
might be a little bit confused but let
me explain what it does in a very simple
way so grep is a tool that allows you to
find strings or patterns in files
alright so that means you can search or
specify for the data or the strings
you're looking for in a particular file
all right so let's take a look at a com
at a concrete example uh we're going to
be looking for a word within a the
proxychains.configuration file now if
you're not familiar with what
proxychains is uh you can check out my
proxy change video where i show how to
set it up uh and install it but again
it's it really doesn't matter because
you can follow up with any other files
you're working with all right so let's
say i
i wanted to find the word dynamic within
the file the cro the proxy chains
configuration file
let's let's take a look at how to use it
using the first method which is using
grep on its own without piping the
output of another command so we can say
grep and then the command we want to
specify after or the parameter
or the variable rather is the the data
we're looking for so again you want to
encapsulate this within double quotation
marks so again if it's a word we can
type in dynamic now the thing you you
must ensure is that this this search
will be case sensitive and i'll show you
how to omit at the case sensitive
searches so let's say we're looking for
the uh the the word dynamic and then we
specify the location of the file we want
to search
for this particular word in so again
proxychains.conf
and again we can use the double tab here
like so and we hit enter and again that
displays the word dynamic chain to us
again that's the the word that it was
able to find within the entire file
however as i said this say
this particular search is going to be
case sensitive now if we want to omit
the case sensitive search we can use the
i parameter or the i argument here
so once we hit i that means that it will
search for all files
or for all words within this particular
file uh
called a dynamic all right so once we
hit enter you can see now it gives us
two lines in the files uh they are both
different in the fact that the first one
is in case and the second one starts
with an uppercase d all right so again
it's a very simple tool to to use and
again you can now see how efficient and
how great it is at finding bits of
information within files so again we can
say let's say we want to look for
particular users within the password
file so i can say grep
and i can say let's say we're looking
for the user alexis in the password file
and then i say etsy
password and we hit enter and then it
displays the user account information
for the user lexis all right so that's
very simply how to use it now let's take
a look at the second method or way of
using grep and that's by piping the
output of one command
into crep and then of course finding the
data you're looking for that way and the
way to do this is by using the pipe the
pipe symbol or the pipe key on your
keyboard now you can find this key on
the extreme right of your keyboard just
before your numpad if you do have one
all right so the way we use it is let's
say we wanted to cut the contents of the
password file so let's say we wanted to
say cat etsy
password and we say we want to look for
a particular string within this file and
to do this with grep we now enter the
pipe symbol
which means we are redirecting the
output of this initial command
and we are now passing it on to grep so
now grep can do something with this
output so we say grep i want you to look
for the word dynamic all right
and we type we hit enter and we and
there you are so again it does not give
us any options here um and that's
because i did not specify user here so
again say alexis and again that gives us
the using the user account information
for the user lexus and again we can just
change it to the
proxychains.configuration file here
and we hit enter and we change this to
dynamic sorry um like so and it gives us
the data now a lot of people have been
asking me since uh since i covered
redirecting output uh as i mentioned
there are two ways of redirecting output
the pipe
key or the pipe command is used to
redirect output and you know further
process the data that you're outputting
the difference between the pipe uh the
pipe uh command or redirecting output
with pipe and the greater than symbol is
the greater than symbol will not display
the information on to your terminal it
will actually just output everything or
redirect all the output of the command
that you have
that you've used into a file or even
another command so again if i say cat
fc password and i use this i wanted to
redirect the output into it uh into a
txt file i can say desktop
and say test.txt and i hit enter and now
if i actually get uh the the the file on
my desktop sorry i believe i'm in my
home directory here and i say test.txt
hit enter it it actually has the content
of the file so again that's the
difference when uh when i'm actually
talking about uh redirecting output with
both the pipe and the greater than sign
uh which is very different so
again the pipe symbol is the preferred
way of using or actually passing the
output of one command and processing it
with another command
like
leg grip and you can use it with other
utilities that will actually show you
how to use uh for the further further
along the series here
so
you can use this with any other command
that displays output onto the screen so
i'm just going to use one more command
just to show you how efficient this is
so let's say i typed in ifconfig and i
just want my inet information i can pipe
the output of the ifconfig command and i
can say i net
uh and i can just say grab i net here
and i hit enter and it gives a it gives
me my inet information whether that be
ipv4 or ipv6 all right so you can now
see how useful this is and i want you
guys to experiment with this let me know
what you think
where you're not understanding how to
use it and i'll be sure to make up for
full follow-up videos if you guys are
interested in it
in this video i'm going to be showing
you how to use the locate utility to
find files and i'll be also making an
another video after this to show you how
to use the find tool to actually find
files as well so they're two utilities
that you can use in this video we're
going to be taking a look at how to use
the locate tool it's a tool that goes
ignored by many beginners or newcomers
mostly because of its relative
simplicity but it's a very efficient
tool and does what it's supposed to do
so again
we can use the what is uh utility here
to tell us more about what this tool is
so again we can just say what is locate
and as you can see it tells us it finds
files by the name which is very simple
and again you can use the manual page
you can use the manual for this
particular tool to learn how to use it
so i'm just going to be covering just
enough to make you efficient with the
tool and make you understand how it
works and how you can use it in
conjunction with grip
all right so
uh let's actually get started with a
very simple example right so let's say i
wanted to locate a file on the system
right and
i wanted to locate a the password file
so i can say locate
password and hit enter and you can see
it's given me a lot of a lot of
information here a lot of files called
password on my system
right now this is really not efficient
because um again i'm looking for a
particular file that i'm looking for
which is bill which actually exists in
the etsy file and we can see the result
well that's not actually the result here
with this is the result right at the top
here all right however this really is
not efficient or an efficient way of
going about it right so uh this is where
we can now specify the options that we
can use
uh that we can use with uh with a tool
like locate so let's say we wanted to
get only the files that match this
particular pattern or these particular
uh strings here so the password string
so to do this we type a or we use the uh
we can use the all parameter or option
here and once we hit enter again that
gives us the same information so what
does that means is it's actually
displaying all the files on the system
uh that actually match the patterns of
password here
and because this file really doesn't
have any extension we now have to deal
with the actual path or the path that we
we might want to be uh finding this file
in now of course that is counter
intuitive given that um
i can say that this belongs in the etsy
in the etsy directory and again that now
it now actually narrows down uh the
files into what they may be so again
that's the the actual file where we were
looking for but you can see how tedious
this is so we can actually shorten this
now by actually using the grep tool
which actually showed you how to use and
it's very very simple so again we're
simply going to use grip to look for
particular information related to the uh
to the information that is is given to
us by locate so we can now say locate
and then we say we're looking for
password and
we close that and now we say we pipe the
output and we say grip let's look for
password uh within etsy within the etsy
directory so again
we can now say etsy here sorry fc and
we say password or we can just say the
etsy directory here and then we can hit
close and you can see it gives us the
results we're looking for it highlights
them in red or depending on the color
scheme you're using in your terminal so
again we can improve the efficiency of
this by typing in
etsy password and we hit enter so this
is a file without a particular extension
which makes it relatively difficult to
actually find but you can find it
relatively easily if you use grep here
um so so let's actually talk about um
about another file that has an extension
that we can use to explain this here
all right so
um let's say we're working with the
the the resolve file or the resolve
configuration file which is used for to
modify your name servers which is
available on our linux systems what we
can say is we can say locate
resolve and uh sorry resolve and we hit
enter and again tons of files but now we
know that this file has an extension so
we can say uh locate it's uh we can say
locate resolve uh dot conf and read
enter and again it still gives us a lot
of files but we're looking for the one
that belongs in the that exists in the
etsy folder again so what we can do now
is we can say locate and we want to
actually
we're looking for we can use the all uh
the old parameter here
and then we say we're looking for
uh all files with an extension or we're
looking for a file with the with an
extension of uh conf or config here so
we'll use the wildcard option to mean
that this we're looking for for all
files with this particular extension so
we say
um all and then we say conf and we close
those um these quotation marks and now
we pipe the output into grep here and
now with grep we can then say we are
looking for resolve here and we sorry
that is we're looking for resolve when
we enter and now it gives us the
information we're looking for
and the first option here so again
that's with the
the actual extension of confirm so again
we're limiting the results to
only the files that have an extension of
config or configuration and then we can
use grep to find the particular string
that is most important to us so let me
give you another example because this
seems very simple
so let's say
we're looking for the proxy chains right
uh so we can say proxy change and hit
enter and there you are you can see
immediately now because that is a unique
string it gives us the results
immediately with the uh we with the uh
the extension here and that's because we
specified it so again we can just say
locate you know proxy chains
and hit enter and there's a ton of files
now another thing you might find useful
is actually
displaying how many results are matching
the particular pattern you have
specified exist so let's say i want to
say locate i can say all that means all
the the the matching uh the matching
patterns here so we say all and then we
can use the c uh the c argument here
which specifies or prints the number of
matching results and then we say we
specify the string we're looking for or
we can just say we're looking for proxy
chains and we enter and it tells us here
that we have 25 uh files
uh or results that actually have the
matching patterns here now if we limit
it to
conf and we hit enter now you can see we
only have two so that's essentially how
to use this tool uh in regards to you
know displaying the amount of matching
uh patterns you have and if you wanted
to locate so if we get rid of this here
and let's hit enter you can now see the
results that it tells us here so we have
the one in the etsy folder and one in
the the debian package management uh
the debian package management folder uh
in regards to its actual configuration
there so
that's how to use the locate tool now
again let me just cover one more
additional parameter you can use and
that is the the eye parameter which
again is very important and that means
that you want to ignore case uh that's
something i should have mentioned
earlier all searches with locate are
typically going to be case sensitive so
again i can say proxy chains
and i hit enter and we have no results
right so if i wanted to ignore the case
sensitivity of what i've just hit uh of
the the pattern i've just entered i can
just hit i and i'd enter and again we
get the same results and i can now limit
this to proxychains.conf and there you
are and again i can i can partner these
or i can actually combine these commands
with each other to give us the
information we're looking for so again a
very very simple tool to use but again
it gives you very consistent results
in this video we're going to be taking a
look at how to enumerate uh system
information on linux now you might be
wondering what exactly do you mean here
well i'm simply referring to uh
important information about your system
and the user currently logged in as just
information that you might need when
you're currently logged onto a system
and you might want to know more about
what you're dealing with all right so
let's get started now the first
uh the the first thing we need to do is
we need to find out what user we're
currently logged in as and the host name
and the use id etc etc all right so
let's get started with that
so the first thing i want to know when
i'm logged in is who am i exactly and
that tells me the current user that i'm
logged in as and then if i type in host
name
uh that again gives me the current
hostname of this workstation or of this
computer in my case it tells me i'm
running uh the hostname is alexis
workstation now if you do want to change
your uh your hostname you can you can do
so by by modifying the host name file i
believe that's what it's called the yeah
there we are and you can see that mine
is set to alexis workstation or ws which
is an abbreviation of workstation so you
can change this and in my case i don't
want to do this so i'm just going to
exit out of here
so that is how to find out the current
user logged in as and the host name
now if you want to find the user id that
you're currently logged in as you can
simply type in id
that gives you the current use id
and again of course the user you then
have the group id which is quite
important and the other groups that this
user is currently a part of
now um
in regards to groups and the groups that
a particular user may be part of the way
to enumerate this information is by
typing in groups and then the name of
the user so we can type in groups alexis
and once we hit enter again it tells us
the user lexis is a part of these groups
so it's a part of the group alexis sudo
among the other ones here that are
essentially system uh system accounts
here that you or system groups that uh
really have to do with just permissions
to a particular service
um so that is basic user enumeration now
let's talk about a little bit about the
system and enumerating information like
um
like your uh
like your linux distribution the version
stuff like that so uh i'm currently
using a debian system or i'm using
ubuntu so again it's based on debian so
the the practices are all the the
techniques and the commands are quite
similar on both ends now when dealing
with uh you know systemd based
distributions
uh and all of course red hat based
distributions the process is going to be
slightly different and i'll explain why
and how
um so on linux if you on sorry on
on on tpn or on ubuntu if you want to
enumerate your linux uh if you want to
enumerate your linux distribution
version and the name you simply type in
lsb release a and of course
lsb is a utility and you may not have it
installed but again it comes with um
with db and ubuntu by default so again
that tells us the distributor the
distributor id the description again
ubuntu 18.04
0.3 lts
the release name
sorry the release version and the code
name here which in this case is bionic
beaver
so again you can also use the check the
contents of the issue file
so if we type in cat etsy issue you can
see it tells us the same thing here
um
so that is for debian based
distributions now um
when dealing with system d distributions
like um
centos arch
red hat
also debian to to some extent you can
also use the you can also take a look at
the content within the os release
file which will also enumerate on debian
as well but i just wanted to explain
that so you guys don't get confused all
right so what you can do is just simply
type in cat let's see
os
os release and again that gives us the
information that we were looking for now
on um on ubuntu and on db and if i hit
enter it tells us nothing there if i
then use the star or the wildcard we hit
enter that gives us the linux
distribution information
and a bit more information regarding the
privacy policy
uh support url stuff like that
and um now that's uh now that we've also
covered the system the uh base
distributions let's talk about uh
dealing with red hat now on red hat um
if you want to take a look at the
uh the red hat release version uh you
can i believe you can find it if i type
in cat hc and then you type in red hat
release now i'm currently not using a
red hat based distribution so that would
pretty much give you the red release
version um so that's basically
enumerating your distribution name uh
your distribution version and name um if
you are using you know some of these uh
distributions based on debian or the
systemd based distributions like arch
centos or red at enterprise linux
so again let's talk about you know
enumerating information about your
processor or your cpu
so you can easily do this by typing your
ls cpu and we can hit enter and again
that enumerates information about your
cpu so it gives you information like
your architecture and the instruction
set
um the amount of uh the amount of cores
the threads per core the cost per socket
sockets
vend id
cpu family the model model name in this
case it's an i5 8400
uh the stepping the
the
frequency here in megahertz so max and
minimum as well so 4 gig by 4 gigahertz
and the minimum of 800 megahertz
uh
virtualization and then the l1 l2 and l3
cache and so information about your cpu
all right so now that we've taken a look
at enumerating cpu information let's
take a look at enumerating kernel uh
information which is done using the you
name
uh
using the unnamed command or utility
which essentially stands for unix name
so again if we just type in what is your
name here and you can see it says prints
system information and guess the name
and information about the current uh
kernel so using it is very very simple
so if you type in your name a that
displays all the information so again it
gives you information about like your uh
your host name the current linux kernel
that's that's installed and currently
running
and then you have the uh you then have
the instruction set here i'm going over
the the important information so again
we can uh we can actually take a look at
the various options that are available
here so again we can say
if we want the kernel uh we if we want
the kernel version here we can type in
uh we can say you name
s and that tells us the kernel that
we're currently running which is the
linux kernel the version here can be
printed out by typing you name
uh i believe it's your name r that's the
current release so in our case it's
version 4.15 which i believe is stable
not too sure
um and then if you want again if you
want the
the information about the the
instruction set for your processor you
can type in your name
you name p
again that gives you the instruction set
in our case x 86 64.
uh and then if we want the hardware
platform we can type in you name i
so we can say you name i
the hardware platform again that's the
that's uh the information in regards to
the architecture and then the operating
system
uh we can say you name
o and it enter gnu linux so again just
basic information regarding your system
but uh the key bits of the important
pieces of information here are your
kernel and the instruction set of course
so that's essentially all the
information uh that you might want to
enumerate regarding your system or you
might be interested in now dealing with
um with disk usage and um disk uh and
disk usage disk space i'll be making a
separate video on that so uh you guys
can stay tuned for that but in regards
to your system this these all the
commands that you can use to find
information about your the current user
that's logged in
uh so again if i type in who again that
tells me the current users that are
logged in in my case it's uh the only
user is alexis so that's just an
additional tidbit so again we've covered
you know the user id the group id and
we've also covered enumerating
distribution information and the kernel
information so
in this video we're going to be covering
how to use the find tool and we'll also
be taking a look at some challenges on
of the wire bandit uh more related to
what we're taking a look at in this
video which is how to correctly utilize
the find command to look for files or
directories within your system so an
extremely uh you know very useful tool
that will really help you save time when
looking for particular files and i'll be
showing you how to use it right now most
efficiently so again we can use the what
is utility to find out more information
about the tool so again it tells you at
this this tool allows you to search for
files and in a directory hierarchy you
can also check out the man pages for
this particular tool
and again you can go through all of this
if you want to i'm going to be covering
all uh the the information that is
necessary or that will make you the most
efficient with this tool
all right so let's get started let's
stop wasting time so using the tool is
very simple we say find and then after
sayings find we need to specify uh the
directory we want to we want to search
in so again we can specify the current
directory that we are currently in uh by
you know using the full stop or the dot
uh or we can specify the entire linux
file system directory which is done by
using a forward slash like so as you
would when navigating directories
or i can specify an individual directory
that i want to uh that i want to search
in so i can say home
alexis which is pretty much the
directory we're working in so what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to search
the entire linux file system directory
which if you're going to do you do
require root or pseudo privileges
otherwise you'll not be able to access
files and directories that you know you
do not have adequate permissions to
access
so i will also add the pseudo command
here
so again we're going to find files
within the linux file system directory
we then specify the other bit of
information that uh will help us
fine-tune our results which is of course
going to be the type that we're dealing
with so the type in regards to the find
command is very simple it simply refers
to what you're dealing with so are you
looking for a file or a directory and
that can be denoted by either using f
for file or d for directory in our case
we're looking for a file so we're just
going to hit file all right so very
simple next we specify the other
variable that again will help us
fine-tune our search results and is very
important which is the name so what is
the name of the file you're looking for
so i can say proxy chains
and i know i'm using the same example
but again i'll show you how robust this
is in a second so i can say
proxychains.conf
and after this i can pretty much hit
enter now the important thing to note
here
is that i can use uh the grep command in
conjunction with find to you know pipe
output and specify configuration files
by themselves similar to what we looked
at when we're taking a look at the
locate tool uh so i can just hit enter
and you can see we found the
configuration file and we didn't have
adequate permission for some files which
is perfectly fine
um so that's how to use the find tool
and i've shown you the various
parameters you can use so you can
specify the type uh the name uh which
i'll show you how to how robust it can
be in a second so let's take a look at
the same example so i'm just going to
say find um and you know we can just say
sudo sudo find
and we say the type is going to be
a file which you can also change to
directory if you are looking for a
directory so for example i can say
directory and then i can say name
and their name is going to be alexis
look for the directory lexis and hit
enter and their ui tells us oh we have
various uh directories here so we can
see we have um
we have the home directory here and a
few other files here that uh i've
actually popped up from my external hard
drive which i don't think are that
important
but there you go that just shows you how
robust this tool is in regards to you
know looking for particular files so you
can change that up so so let's go back
to our previous example so i'm just
going to say the name is going to be
proxy chains now i mentioned in the
previous video the the case sensitivity
which is quite important so if you are
performing a search
uh in which you do not want any case
sensitivity you use the i name command
instead of the name command and then
after this you can say i can say alexis
for example and of course it will ignore
all the cases here so i can you know i
can combine it with whatever uppercase
up and lowercase uh characters i want
and i'll still get i'll still get the
same results
uh and i can just hit enter
and uh this time again it gave us uh the
same results but uh it gave us different
results because we are looking for a
file so if we change this into a
directory here you can see that it's
going to give us the same results that
we had in the in the initial run when
we're looking for uh you know
directories uh called alexis so that's
how robust this tool is so i talked
about using um using extensions which is
again very very simple so let's say
we're looking for extensions and we're
looking for all uh conf files which
belong in the etsy directory so i'm just
going to say etsy and we've now written
it down we can say name is going to be
i can say um
uh we can just say conf and we'll use
the wildcard uh so i say conf we'll just
use the same configuration file
extension
uh and then i can say grep and then i
specify the name of the file right so uh
you know i can hit enter and this is
going to display all the configuration
files within the etsy directory but
again i have to specify the
uh the file specification here and i'm
going to enter
and there you are so it gives you all
the configuration files so very simple
tool to use now let's talk about the
other variables that you can use to
specify
that will help you fine-tune your your
search results and that is by specifying
the size of the file
and the permissions all right so again
we can just use a simple example i'm
just going to say find and i'm going to
say we'll say type and that's going to
be you don't really need to specify the
type if you don't want to it's just
there to help you fine tune your results
so i can perfectly ignore it if i know
what i'm looking for
precisely i can then say you know name
and the name is going to be proxy chains
i can say epoxychains.conf you know i
have the whole name
and then i can say size i'm looking for
a file with a particular size so i can
then use the various options i have so i
can say it's going to be plus one
megabyte which can be done like so uh or
i can you know i can save plus a hundred
megabytes whatever i want to say so in
this case let me just say plus one
megabytes and hit enter
and uh well we're getting uh various
permission errors here and that's
because we'll just say etsy
hit enter
and i will say sudo and
there we are and we got no results at
all i just wanted to to actually provide
it with the adequate the adequate
permissions so that i can show you that
if we use uh you know
if we use parameters like these size and
we specify it down to due to the actual
size of the file we can sort of uh
fine-tune our results very very uh to a
very deep granular level
so if i just um
let's say um etsy and i can then grab
proxy chains
conf and
i hit enter here you can take a look at
let me just change this to a human
readable format so you can say it's
about uh four kilobytes here and uh we
can then you know you can specify the
size depending on on how you want it and
i'll get back to this uh when we'll be
taking a look at the uh the over the
wire banded challenges because that's
where i really want to showcase the
power of the fine tool
let's talk about permissions before we
actually get started with at the over
the wire bandit challenges and the
permissions are very simple to to
actually specify here i'm going to be
covering you know users and groups and
we'll be taking a look at that example
but let's talk about uh permissions
first so permissions allow you to find
again files that have particular
permissions very very straightforward
here so you know i can say um
let's say i create a file go to my
desktop here and i'll say touch
alexis dot sh you know just a simple
shell script or a bash script here hit
enter and i say chmod
400 alexis dot sh and hit enter and they
say find within
the home directory i can then say
let's say we're looking for a file
type is going to be a file we don't have
a name but we have permissions so i can
say firm
let's look for
let's look for files with the permission
of 400 which means
um
which means that the the the owner or
the user can read the file um but the
other group and all other users on the
system are not able to access it so
again uh that should give us a few
results but we don't have adequate
permissions for the other files so you
can see we get the result right over
here so you can use permissions to help
fine-tune your search results and get
the exact results you're looking for
you know we can also specify 744 we hit
enter and uh
it looks like we had a few files with
those particular permissions but
nothing no no important files that we
that don't have the correct permission
so you can see that this can help you
find a files on your system that have
incorrect permissions and then you can
rectify them uh you know like so instead
of going manually and checking for their
permission so very useful tool now that
we've taken a look at how to use the
tool let's take a look at how to
implement it in some challenges and
that's what we're going to do in the
next step which is the over the wire
challenges so you can follow along if
you want to and i'll see you there
all right so we are back on over the
wire and i'm currently on the bandit uh
on the bandit web page here and uh you
you can get access to this challenge by
following the instructions on level zero
uh the levels we're interested in are
going to be levels four five
uh level fours uh to level four to level
six so again we'll just go to level four
here and i currently have access and
i've solved the challenges uh all
all up till level four so we can get
started
all right so
uh you can see that uh level four
pertains uh
actually finding a file so you can see
the password for the next file or for
the next level is stored in the in the
only human readable file
in the in here directory uh tip if your
terminal is messed up you can try the
reset command and again it gives you the
various commands that you can use to
solve this level so again let's go back
into our terminal as you can see i'm
currently on bandit 4 and we can list
the files within this home directory and
you can see we have an in here directory
so let's uh let's go in here let's see
what's going on
so if you list the files here you can
see we have various files and if i if i
try cutting one of these uh one of these
files you can see that um
sorry let's specify that hyphen there
let's say file zero zero we can hit
enter and you can see it has a various
uh
it has various pieces of data and of
course our job is to look for files
within this in here directory that have
uh human readable data so again what we
can do is we can use the find command
here uh to actually find uh you know the
various files that have human readable
data so i can say uh in this current
directory and we are looking for um
[Music]
we can actually just say find and then
in this directory uh we're looking for
the type
it's going to be a type of file here and
then we can grip the output or we can
pipe the output sorry and within we can
use the x args command here to look for
um i believe it's uh if we just expand
this uh let's take a look at how to use
x cogs one more time
uh we wanted to display uh the file read
items from a file uh instead of standard
uh standard input
uh
and yeah this if we type in file that
should tell us the files that we're
dealing with all right and this will
help us shorten the process so let's go
back in here as we say file in it enter
and as you can see it tells us that in
file 0 7 we have some ascii text however
in all the other files we have data so
again we can access this file now we can
just cap the contents of this file and
we should get the password next level
all right excellent so we can copy this
let me exit and we'll go to bandit level
five here i'm going to enter we'll just
paste in the password
and we can get started now all right so
let's take a look at what a challenge or
level five uh pertains
so again it says the password for the
next level is stored in a file somewhere
under the in here directory and has all
of the following properties it's human
readable um okay all right it's going to
be a human readable file um 1033 bytes
in size
and it's not executable all right so
that's uh an option these are all the
these are all parameters that we'll have
to specify to some extent
so let's actually get started so
uh these are going to be in the in here
directory so i'll just go into the in
here directory and you can see we have
uh other directories within this so
we're going to just say find
uh and we're going to say type is going
to be a file uh we were told that we
have it's going to be human readable so
you can use x args there
uh
size i showed you how to specify size
now the the thing about specifying size
in bytes is if we just take a look at um
we take a look at the at the find tool
and we just
grip for some for size you can see that
it tells us the size does not count
indirect blocks uh
etc so size one megabyte is not
equivalent is not equivalent to size so
if you're specifying it in bytes you
need to specify uh the actual number and
then the c here all right so that's what
we have to do so um we just go back in
here and we go to type a file and then
we say size
is going to be 10 33 c and then after
this um
we're supposed to us
the file is not
is not executable so we can then use the
logic um operators here so we're going
to say
not executable and executable is another
parameter you can specify and then we
can use xrx here
and we're going to say file and hit
enter
and you can see it tells us
that maybe here07 and file2 has some
ascii text with very long lines all
right so let's cut the content off this
file
and just get it we're just going to
enter here and we have the password so
let's exit and go on to the final level
in this particular video so i'm gonna
go into level six hit enter
and i'm gonna paste the password in here
and we can now take a look at what level
six pertains
uh so level six the password for the
next level is stored somewhere on the
server and has all of the following
properties so yeah this is now where we
have the user and group specifications
which is really simple so again we're
told to look for a file
on the entire server
owned or the the entire linux file
system that is owned by the user bandit
seven
and is owned by the group bandit six and
in 33 bytes in size all right so we can
then say um
it's on the entire server we have any
files here no we don't so we can say
find and we're looking for a user which
is going to be bandit seven and a group
which is again very easy to specify
group is going to be bandit 6
the particular file we're looking for is
going to be
33 bytes so 33c
[Music]
i think that's pretty much it in regards
to the options or the parameters that we
were given so let's actually see if we
can find this file when it enter
and
we get various
you know permission denied errors here
and it looks like we get a password file
here so that's under the var folder or
the var directory and it's a bandit 7
password so let's copy the directory do
that the actual file path the relative
file path and cat the contents of that
and we get the password to the next
level and i'm just going to hit exit and
we can move on to bandit level 7 which
is now
is is going to pertain to another
challenge which is out of the scope of
this video so
in this video i'm going to be talking
about shells now this might be a little
bit confusing for you if you're a
beginner to linux but um
you the only thing you need to
understand is that your the various
types of shields you can use on linux
now if you're using ubuntu or debian the
default shell that you'll be you'll be
given is going to be called the bash
shell all right and again i can confirm
this by echoing my variable my shell
variable here so i can say echo shell
and again it tells you the the current
shell that i'm using which is bash now
bash is an acronym for the born again
shell
uh so that means that there was a born
shell and you're familiar with it and
that is the sh or the sh shell so uh
all of these shells can be used to to
actually work with the linux system
that's that's entirely up to you my
objective in this video is to explain
how to change your default shell and not
work with the bash shell
all right now
on linux if you want to actually display
all the shelves that you currently have
that can be used uh you can essentially
just read the contents
of the shells file in the etsy directory
and i can hit enter and you can see it's
going to tell me it's going to tell you
the valid login shells you have
so we have the born shell which is the
sh we have the born again shell which is
bash which is the preferred
shell to use you then have our bash and
dash which is pretty good and then you
have fish now i just installed fish and
again many of you have been asking me to
cover this i'll explain it after i've
after actually explained passion how to
use it how to customize it and stuff
like that so for the purpose of this
video i'm going to be using i'm going to
be using bash and i'll later on cover
the other the other shelves that you can
use and you know using fish
so the first thing is how to switch from
shell to shell within a given terminal
instance
so i'm currently using the bash shell if
i wanted to switch into the bond shell i
can just hit sh and hit enter and you
can see i'm now in the bond shell and
again all the linux commands work
perfectly fine i can hit all the various
linux commands that i could run so i can
list all the files in here etc etc you
get the idea right so i can then say cat
etsy shelves and again we can take a
look at the shelves we have i can now go
back into bash
i can go into dash if i want to and
again that takes me to in into into dash
you can say echo and we can again
confirm this and hit enter and it tells
us we're still in pin bash that is
because we're currently within this
instance but if i changed it as my
default login shell which i'll show you
in a second how to do so let me just go
back into bash
and we will actually let me just clear
this out so there we all right so
you can see how easy it is to switch
between shells in a particular terminal
instance now
by default as a user account on a linux
system
uh a
you will be specified a particular shell
to use and that can be found in the
password file so if i hit enter so let
me just grab it and display my account
you can see that the shell is specified
here and i'll explain this when talking
about users and groups you can see that
uh the default login shell that i have
been specified to use is the bash shell
which is perfectly fine now the great
thing about linux is when creating the
user you can specify the shell that
they're going to use however you can
also change the shell of the user or the
user can change the shell that they want
to use when they log in or every time
they log in and the way we do that is by
using the change shell command or the
change shell utility which is defined by
chsh or that's an actual abbreviation of
the command so i can type in what is
chsh
and i'm going to enter you can see it
tells you this allows you to change the
login shell
all right so if i want to change uh the
default login shell all i need to do is
let me first display the shells that i
have here one more time all i need to
specify is their relative path all right
so if i say chs8 it's going to ask me
for the password of my user here when it
enter and it's going to say changing the
login shell for the user lexis enter new
value or press enter for the default the
default login shell for me is bash so if
i wanted to change it to
to fish for example i would say
user
sorry that is user
bin and i say fish i'm going to enter
and that changes it for me all right so
what this means in essence if i type in
cat hc password here
what this means
let me just display the results here you
can see that it changes uh the default
login shell so this means that uh when i
log out and i log back in
uh what's gonna happen is that i'm gonna
be given the fish shell as my default
shell instead of bash so if you're
wondering what the fish shell is uh you
can install it very easily by typing
sudo apt install or apt-get install
whatever you find is useful for you
just hit enter and i already have it
installed so that's how to install it so
what is fish fish is a friendly as a
friendly interactive show it's a great
show for beginners extremely
customizable and you can see once i
typed in fish it allowed me to log in
the great thing about fish is it allows
allows me to actually it actually gives
me predictions in regards to the
commands that i might be interested in
running we'll get to this in a second
let me go into bash
all right so that is how to change your
default login shell
all right so again i'm right now i'm
currently set to use fish as the default
shell when i log in every time
but let's talk about bash because that's
uh that that's the primary goal of this
video because it's the most used shell
and the one you'll be coming across
mostly so in my current home directory
so in the user lexis directory here i
have various bash files bash
configuration files uh within this
directory so i'm just gonna grab them
and i'll say bash and of course they're
gonna be hidden
so i'm just gonna hit enter and as you
can see i have a bash aliases file which
you're not going to have by default i
created this and i created it to to
prove a point and to actually
demonstrate an example here we then have
the bash history uh file which has uh
all your history of all your commands
and this is very different to your
actual
gnu history uh utility
um
you have bash log out and bash rc bash
rc is your bash configuration file i'm
not gonna cover how to configure it it's
extremely straightforward and you can
pretty much configure it directly uh by
using the preferences tab right over
here
but we can take a look at it i just want
to show you how it is so and if we take
a look at it here through vim you can
see that
it essentially allows you to to
configure set
variables i change the color change the
the size of the history of the history
file um
let's see what else you can actually do
here so there you can you can change the
color
this is all to do with color and you can
you can do a lot of other stuff with uh
in regards to customizing how it appears
and and how it works so for example if i
wanted um if i wanted bash to actually
run the fish shell instead of the bash
shell every time i started up
i started bash up i would type in fish
right just at the bottom here and let me
save this file now and if i open up a
new terminal you can see immediately it
opens up the fish shell
so that's pretty cool but this isn't the
correct way of doing it or the preferred
way of doing it so i'll just get rid of
this fish command here
and i'll save the changes here all right
so now that we've talked about um
now that we've talked about the bash rc
file let's talk about the bash history
file which is very important all right
so
by default in linux you have the history
command um which again let me just type
it in the history command is essentially
the new history library now the the
history uh
this essentially allows you to to
actually check uh a lot it stores a
history of all the commands you've run
and uh you know you can clear your
history very easily by typing in history
c right and it's as simple as that but
it's not to be mistaken or confused with
bash history which is again uh
is specific to the bash shell or the
bone again shell
so again this file will contain a list
of all the commands that i've run and
and i'll show you how to clear it so if
i get the contents of the file
uh you can see that it it has all of
these commands that i've been running so
far you know perfectly fine
and if i wanted to clear it it's very
easy i can just redirect the the
contents of the so i can say dev
null and then
[Music]
i can redirect the output into the
actual bash history file they bash
history here hit enter clear this out
if i now try and catch the contents of
the bash history file
you can see it has nothing so i've been
able to clear my bash history i think
i've covered this in my one of the
videos where i spoke about uh actually
clearing your tracks on linux so this is
a great way of doing that and of course
you can then use the history command if
you want to do that so that's to do with
actually using the um
with actually working with the actual
bash history here now let me talk about
the bash aliases file all right so the
aliases file is very simple it allows
you to specify aliases or command
aliases that you'd like to use now you
can just create a file within your home
directory and just name it bash aliases
so what i'll do is i'll actually just
show you the contents of the file
so i can just show it show it to you
right over here so bash aliases hit
enter and you can see i have two aliases
i have alias update which runs the
command sudo apt-get update and then i
have upgrade which runs the command sudo
apt-get upgrade so it's fairly simple to
understand what happens so i can just
type in update and that will update my
packages and then i can type in upgrade
and that will upgrade my packages
instead of typing the commands over and
over again so that is what
you know the command aliases are and how
to specify them so again it's very
simple in regards to configuring it
in this video i'm going to be showing
you uh how to enumerate intermission in
regards to your current disk usage and
in information you know in regards to
how much storage your system is
consuming how much you have left the
various disks attached to your system
etc stuff like that
all right so as i said in the previous
videos in regards to enumerating you
know information about your system it's
very important to know uh the state of
view system and that you know could
include the current ram usage uh what
you the temperature of your processes
are you know so again it's very
important to know as a system
administrator or someone who is going to
be you know using linux uh you know more
and more every day uh how to enumerate
information and useful information like
your current disk usage
and the various drives that you have
installed on your system so let's talk
about disk usage first which is quite
important right because when working
with the terminal you have no gui you
know programs
that can actually you know visualize
this for you so it's very important that
you understand how to do this extremely
important so the tool we're going to be
using is a tool called du right and
again it's fairly straightforward what
that means that means disk usage so i
can just say what is what is du and i
can hit enter and as you can see it
tells you this allows you to estimate
file space usage right
now du is a very simple tool to use and
you can take a look at the man pages or
in regards to how how to use it
um so let's actually just run a simple
command within this current directory
and i'll show you what i mean so if i if
i hit du
uh you can see that
this is um there's something weird
happening here right so it's displaying
a lot of files and uh when i say that it
really is displaying it's displaying all
the sizes of all the files within this
directory recursively all right now you
might be saying well what does that mean
exactly
well it means that it's actually showing
you the size of all the files within a
current working directory all right
that's essentially what it means now
what current directory am i working in
i'm working in my home directory so we
need to make this a little bit more
human readable and the way we do this is
by typing du and then we specify some
arguments the first thing we want to do
is we want to summarize
all of these results into a uh into a
format that we can understand right so
instead of displaying recursively all
the files here show us the top level
directories and the total sizes of those
directories and then we can go
recursively within those particular
directories if we wanted to all right so
the s command is going to summarize
everything up and then we want to use
the h command the human readable format
within this current working directory
and i'm going to hit enter
and as you can see right over here tells
you it gives you a beautiful list of all
the directories you have in this
particular directory and on the left
hand side you have their sizes in human
readable format which means they have uh
they have that they have size uh they
have uni their various units in
megabytes and in gigabytes
and you know so far the the only file
that's crossed at the threshold of one
gigabyte is my virtualbox folder so
again you can use a tool like trep to if
you're going through tons of files on a
system i'm just using simple examples
here so you know i can say grep and you
know i can say one uh one gig and we can
hit enter and again that can be used to
enumerate all of these all of this type
of information or i can just say g
g would be much better and there you are
so again that's how to use grep in
conjunction with all of these commands
so that's how to use the disk usage tool
now again i can go on to my um let me
just go uh
actually let's let's just go into the
linux file system itself and say sudo uh
eush and we'll run the same command and
again we can hit enter and again that
starts to enumerate the sizes of all of
these directories now mind you it has to
go through all of these directories and
the subdirectories uh directories
recursively to get this size so again
for some particular files
you will not have the adequate
permissions to actually access so again
there you are it gives you uh all the
information you're looking for here and
we can you know we can grab it to we're
looking for the the big g for a gigabyte
so the home directory has quite a
few files the media directory uh the
snap swap file user var etc etc
um so let's take a look at one command
i'll just go back into my home directory
and i'll say man eu and we'll hit enter
let's look for one
one more command that yes the c command
which will produce a grand total which i
wanted to explain so i can say to you
shc and hit enter and again that gives
you a total of um
it gives you a total of all of these
files
uh it gives you a total of all of the
files and directories in this current
working directory all right so that's
pretty much how to use the disk usage
tool
uh to analyze the current disk usage
within a particular directory now let's
talk about the df tool so i can type in
what is the fn8 enter and this is going
to report file system disk space usage
so we were talking about disk usage in a
particular directory right but now we
want to know our disk usage in relation
to the total amount available right so
we want to know how much we've consumed
uh
in our current uh disk where we have our
home directory or just on all our drives
right and to do this we type in df so
again let me just open up the man pages
so df
um you can go through all the other
arguments you want and we'll just quit
and we'll say df for example
all right so
that displays a lot of information here
that we we really don't need
we're pretty much looking for our our
system disks uh only
and uh we can sort of narrow this down
first of all by typing in so we can say
df h is going to be for human readable
format so again we can say man df and we
say grep
we're looking for h
like so
and uh
sorry let me just uh we're looking for h
here
so again h is for human readable format
all right so we can then say dfh
and we can pretty much hit enter all
right and what this does now is it's
going to display
all of all of your drives for you here
and you then have the various so for
example storage device c is the current
uh file uh the current drive that i have
my system installed on so it gives you
uh it sorts it out into the file system
size and a human readable format so
gigabyte megabyte etc uh the amount used
the amount available the usage
percentage and where it's mounted so
uh you can see that dev sd storage
device c1 is mounted is the actual linux
file system directory i then have
various other
external right so let's say i just
wanted to display the storage devices
right so i can you then utilize the grep
tool i can say
uh i can say grip uh sd and hit enter
and there we are so it tells me all
right so um you have sd sdc one and sdd1
so sdc1
has a total space of 117 gigabytes um
and again we can what we can do here is
uh we yeah
that's perfectly fine so you have the um
you have the current usage percentage
which is 16 percent uh the amount point
and then for my external drive
you can see uh this is the total amount
available uh the amount used the amount
remaining and the usage percentage and
where it's mounted on which is the media
because it's an external drive
all right so
that is essentially how to use the df
tool now we can specify
additional options to uh to to actually
only display
results that we're looking for in
regards to um to actually file file
system formats so if you're looking for
xt for ntfs what we can do is we can say
uh we can say df h t right so t will
specify the the file system for format
so again we can say xt4 and we hit enter
and that's going to only it's going to
it's only going to display linux file
systems and i'm going to enter and you
can see it tells us sdc1
and it gives us all the relevant
information regarding the the size used
uh used uh data the amount available and
the usage percentage which is currently
at 16
so again that is how to analyze your
disks uh your disk usage on linux and uh
how to you know actually deduce how much
disk space you're using how much is left
the usage amount of where your various
disks are mounted on etc etc
uh in this video going to be talking
about creating archives so you know
creating tar files dart or gzip files
and then extracting them so just how to
manage and maintain the various archives
you will be creating now there are many
reasons to create archives on linux of
course one of the reasons is it saves
space uh you can if you're taking
backups of particular directories uh
it's great to have an autumn an
automated script to to actually automate
the process of archiving the files uh
that's something that you can take a
look at with my shell scripting series
uh the link to that will be in the
description section if you're interested
in learning some shell scripting
uh but let's get started with this video
so uh the tool we're gonna be using is
the tar tool now tar is an archiving
utility as you can see here and again if
we if we take a look at the man pages
for this particular tool uh it gives you
the various options that you can use you
know in regards to creating uh archives
comparing them deleting them etc so
there's a lot of stuff in here
the purpose of this video is to show you
uh or to and to explain to you how to
create uh how to create archives uh how
they differ in terms of the extension
and of course how to extract the various
archives that i
that you'll come across
all right so uh on my desktop what i've
done is um i've created a simple
directory here uh let me just uh remove
this uh
this directory right over here um there
we are and um so i created a directory
called file
and within this directory uh you can see
that i've created a
a test.txt file that contains uh the
contents of the password file so just a
random file that you know you may want
to uh you may want to archive or random
directory that you you may want to
archive so if i wanted to create a tar
archive of this file directory what i
would do is i would say tar and then i
would specify
you know some arguments here
in in regards to what i want star to do
so first of all i would want dart to
compress the file
um and then of course i want uh i wanted
to compress
this file so we're specifying the file
um now after this we specify the name of
the archive that we want to give it so
we'll just call it file dot dar this is
different than a dar.gz
archive and i'll explain how that
differs shortly so then we specify the
the directory that we want to actually
archive and we hit enter
and there you are so you can see it
created uh the tar file for us and of
course if we type in um file and
file.tar you can see it tells you that
this is a tar archive gnut or archive
here so that means it was it worked
correctly now um
let me remove this uh the star archive
here and if we run the same command that
we did
sorry about that let me just um let me
let's do it one more time so you can say
tar
we can also use the uh the v command and
that will give us some verbose output in
regards to what files are currently
being processed uh you know in the
overall archiving uh process so again we
can say tar cvf
and then we say dar we can just say
file.um
file.tar and then we specify the
directory and we hit enter and you can
see it then gives you a the post output
and we get the dar the file.tar archive
here so
if we want to extract a tar archive
that's a very very simple thing to do
all we need to do is we say tar
guitar
and now that we want to extract it we
use the x command uh by the way you can
you can negate or not use the iphone
here but i personally like using the
iphone just so that i understand where
my syntax is going so i can say extract
and we can verbose you know we can have
some verbose output
and we say extract
the file and then we specify the file so
we say file.tar and then we can provide
an output for it or you can just hit
enter and it you know it extracts it for
us and because we already have the file
here uh it will essentially overwrite
the
uh the newer files if the if there are
any new changes etc so we can uh
we can remove this directory and do that
one more time here so we can say star
xvf
file dot r and we hit enter now if we
list this you can see that we have the
file directory here all right excellent
so that's uh working with star files and
that's you know a standard tar
a guitar file here uh now let's talk
about gzip files so if i say what is
gzip and uh you can do this with star
again uh it's a very very simple you
that's the preferred way of doing it so
uh let's take the um
the same or we can just remove the file
dot our here so let's take the same
file directory here and if we want to
now use the or compress it
into a third or gzip file
using gzip of course then we would say
tar
uh now we are compressing it so we say c
z uh f or c z c v z f or c z v f
whatever you want to use in our case we
we don't want to work or we want to
display uh you know some the verbose
output so we can just use the czf
and then we specify um
we specify the name so we're going to
say file.tar
register and then we specify the
directory that we want to archive or
compress and we hit enter
and you can now see that we created the
gz file here so if we type in file and
then you know just to find out what
we're dealing with the ui tells you
we're dealing with a gzip compressed
data
so again we can extract it really simply
by saying dar
um dar x z f
x z f and then we say file
dot r g z but uh before we do this uh
let's remove uh let's remove the actual
file directory here so we say term
x zf and then we say
file.gz and we hit enter and it'll then
give us the file directory which is
right over here so again we can cut the
contents just to show you that it's
worked just fine
um
you can see that it's the entire content
of the password file so that's pretty
much how to work with archives i'm not
going to be covering the various other
utilities that you can use so for
example bc2 which is again very simple
use uh in regards to using bzip2 for
compression i wanted to show you how to
use the tar uh guitar utility for
archiving files archiving them and then
of course extracting them so it's the
most reliable and consistent way of
working with archives on linux and it's
great for you know taking backups and
with the help of a shell script you can
easily automate the process
in this video i'm going to be talking
about uh you know adding managing users
and groups and then in the follow up
videos we'll be talking about user
security and sort of securing the
authentication uh section or area of of
linux so let's get started now i just
want to give you a bit of a premise
i'm currently running a um currently
logged in by ssh onto one of my uh linux
servers and the reason being is as we
move on into this series to to the end
or to the completion uh i'll be covering
security uh you know various security
aspects that we will require a lot of
testing so again uh that's primarily the
reason so let's get started now by
default
uh you can see that i've created another
user called admin
and i'm currently running ubuntu server
so
what's going to happen is uh it is
recommended never to only be using the
root user and that you need to have
another user in which you can then uh
start you know applying various
permissions to so by default on ubuntu
uh when working with users again is a
very very simple syntax in regards to
adding them so what we're going to do is
we're just going to create a user here
we're just going to say user add and you
can take a look at all the uh the
various options you can use when
specifying a user
so if i just say uh user add and i hit
enter you can see it doesn't give me any
prompt but if i say user add alexis and
i hit enter it will give me
an error with the um
it will give me an error with with a
lack of permissions now i did this uh
you know deliberately so that i can
demonstrate uh how to use groups before
we actually take a look at that so i'll
just switch i'll just switch into the
root user here
and we'll go into my home directory and
we'll just say v sudo here uh so we'll
say v sudo and
what we want to do now
is we have the user admin uh but we want
to
we want to actually have this user
[Music]
we want to add this user admin into the
sudo group which will essentially allow
members of the group to execute any
command now i can do that or i can also
add them to the admin to the admin group
which which would be better
um so again we can sort of customize the
various uh the various commands that we
can specify and i'll get to this in a
second so
uh what we want to do now is i'll just
exit and i'll say user mod
and i'll say user mod a
g
ad group and then we say
admin and the user admin and we hit
enter and that's going to add the user
admin into the group admin so you
specify the group first and then the
user there that might might seem a bit
confusing but if i just say groups uh
groups admin you can see that it tells
me that the user admin is in the group
admin all right so if we go back into
the user admin here
you can see it tells you to run a
command as administrator use
user root use the sudo command so again
we now have permissions to do whatever
we want so if we go back here
we can say sudo user add
user add and
again that will give us the same option
so if we say user ad alexis
uh it's going to add the user now the
problem with this if i display the
password file
you can see that the user alexis by
default will be given a home directory
that's perfectly fine and the diff the
default shell will be set to the bond
shell so what i want to do is let me
show you how to remove a user so to
remove a user we say user dell and then
if we want to remove their home
directory
we say uh r or we use the recursive
command and then we specify the user so
we can say alexis
and again we need to use um
the
we need to use the sudo command here
because we require root privileges so
it's going to remove
it's going to remove the user so if we
just display the
uh the contents of the home directory we
can see that the only user directories
we have are for the user admin all right
so now that i've explained that let me
show you the correct syntax for adding a
user here so again i can just say user
ad now
uh in regards to the actual commands you
can use you can take a look at the man
pages uh sorry um
user ad and you can take a look at all
of these options and there's a quite
extensive options you can use in regards
to creating user but in our case we want
to say user ad and um
the first thing we want to do is we want
to make sure that this user has a home
directory with its username appended so
we can say m
and then we can add a comment so again
this can describe uh you know something
about the account and what it's used for
we can just say alexis and we can then
specify the shell this is very important
if you want a uh
if you want the user account to to use a
custom shell
in our case we'll just say bin bash and
then we specify the name of the user
account or the username and we hit enter
all right so again it tells us we need
sudo privileges so let's add that and
i'll just hit enter and the the user is
added now this user doesn't have a
password yet so to add a password for a
user we can say we can use the password
command all right and again it requires
root
privileges
so if i wanted to change the password
for the admin account or for the current
account that i'm using i simply type in
password and it'll say changing password
for admin and it'll ask me for my
current password
i'll enter a new password here
and the password isn't changed so i just
wanted to demonstrate this so again i
can just say let me just change the
password here
and i'll just change it to something
different and there we are so the
password for the admin user has been
updated successfully
if i wanted to change the password for
another user i would say password alexis
and hit enter
so again we we can use the sudo
privileges because we're now modifying
and
sorry about this let's just add um
and there we are so now we've added the
password for the user lexis so i can
directly switch uh into this user
account and i'll show you something
interesting here so i can say sudo
alexis
um and i switch into it and um
there we are so now if i try and do
something like sudo apt update here
uh it'll ask me for the user for the
password and um well i think i entered
the correct the incorrect password here
so if i enter the correct password you
can see it's going to tell us that
alexis is not in the sudoes file this
incident will be reported all right so
that's um that's essentially telling us
we don't have adequate adequate
permission so if we go back into the
admin account
um
we can now play around with the sudoers
file so again we'll say sudo vsudo and
we'll hit enter and let's talk about now
adding permissions and before we
actually take a look at groups
right so typically with ubuntu uh you
can see that it gives you all of these
various groups you know right out of the
bat and you you can specify specific
user privileges
under this right over here so you can
see for the root user um
it can run it from all uh sessions
irregardless of whether it's a tty uh or
a remote session
uh and then you know for all users in
all groups and it can run all commands
so again again just say alexis and let's
say all or you know i can just simply
say
uh all sorry that's always going to be
equal to all and so that's pretty much
uh all users um
and then in regards to the command
specification which you specify here so
this user can actually run all
permissions or i can limit it to you
know certain permissions if i want to
right now again
this will pretty much
this this will pretty much allow me to
to actually run uh specific commands so
for example if i wanted to only allow
this user to say for example user bin
apt
get
for example um so what i'll do is i'll
just save this file and we'll go back
into the user lexis here
um and we'll say
and then we say sudo apt get and many of
you might be catching on and you'll see
what happens here
so you can see that that works now and
we're able to run only that command with
root privileges
so we'll just wait for this to actually
update the repositories
let's try and run another command with
root privileges and i'll show you what
will happen here so
again my apologies my internet is
really not that quick um so we'll just
wait for this to complete
and um
so there we are
got the repos and you know i can pretty
much install software and i can use the
app to get a utility so if i say sudo
um let's say vim
hc
ssh sshd config if we open this you can
see we're not allowed to do this so if
we go back into the admin user
you can see now this is a great way of
you know specifying um specifying
permissions for users so
additionally what i can do is i can use
groups right now
i have the user alexis here and let me
just comment this if i say all commands
uh that means it can run all commands
here without any uh without any
restrictions so we then have groups
right now groups
allow
groups essentially allow users to allows
you to group users you know based on
their particular role or
responsibilities now in this case we
have two groups we have admin and sudo
and they essentially allow users to
execute all commands with root
privileges here
um so
uh what we can do is uh we can create
another group here so uh
we can just exit out of this uh well
actually no
we can just modify this one more time
because uh i want to actually comment
this in regards to the permissions here
so we'll just exit and let's talk about
groups all right so let's talk about
groups in linux now groups are a great
way of sort of collectively applying
permissions to you know groups of users
that you know you may want to have uh
you know the same privileges uh or
permissions uh and you know it's a great
way of
blanketing
various permissions on different users
and a great way of of course segregating
roles and duties within a system so it's
a great way of actually actively
uh
actively approaching uh the whole idea
of segregation of roles and duties so
let's talk about uh creating groups uh
deleting groups and of course working
with permissions with groups so we're
going to follow this the same scenario
we have the admin user uh and of course
we then have the user alexis here so the
user lexis currently is not part of any
any any particular group so again it's a
standard user account that doesn't have
root privileges and is simply just
allowed to operate within those
constraints now if i wanted to add a
group here i would say group add right
and then i'll specify the name of the
group so let's say we want to add the
the user alexis to a group called
developers
right so we're going to say group add
developers let me just prepend this with
sudo because we do need root privileges
to create new groups and we're going to
hit enter all right so now we have the
group created so if we want to display
groups for a particular user or the
groups that a user is in again we use
groups and then the name of the user
and you it tells you that alexis
currently is is in its own group we can
view all the groups on the system by
visiting the or cutting or displaying
the contents of the group a file if we
hit enter you can see that we have the
various groups and you can see we have
all the system accounts as well as
pretty much they're going to be in their
own group unless
uh specified otherwise
um so let's uh let what we're gonna do
is we're going to add the user alexis
into this developers group and then i'll
show you how permissions can sort of be
uh be manipulated that way so we're
gonna say user mod and we're gonna say
we're gonna append append
the user lexis and we're going to say
the group by the way you can use a
lowercase g here the lowercase g
primarily means you need to specify the
group ids in our case we'll just use the
capital g because we know the names of
head
so we'll say developers and we want to
add the user alexis to the group
developers
i believe we need root privileges for
this so i'm going to enter and that
should do it all right so now if i say
groups alexis you can see that alex is
going to be part of its own group and
uh
and the developers group now when we
talk about having its own group that
simply refers to you know user specific
privilege specifications so again if we
visit the uh the v sudo uh utility uh to
modify the sudoes file
you can see that we talked about user
user privilege specification and we had
actually added a uh you know some
privileged specifications for the user
alexis where
you know we can access it from all hosts
and we've specified all users however
not all groups so this essentially will
restrict
uh this will restrict
the user alexis uh
and it will essentially allow him to run
uh you know the apt-get utility with
root privileges here
however
that's one way of doing it so if if i
use this if i use this this same syntax
uh then i can also you know allow it to
run all commands
and you know i can also specify the uh
the exp explicitly to refuse
to refuse it to use the root uh to
actually have pseudo privileges so it
will only run this command
uh and and you know so on and so forth
so i can do that actively if i wanted to
however i don't want to so what we'll do
is let's just test this out to see that
it works and of course you can change
this to whatever
whatever command that will require you
know root privileges so we can just use
app to get here and i'll save this now v
sudo when saving and exec
and exiting if you do have a syntax
error it will tell you so again if we go
here and we say
let's uh let let's actually mess around
with the syntax here so again i can just
say add a few uh commas there you can
see that it tells us uh in the etsy
pseudo as well as syntax error near line
21 and we can use the e command to edit
it so again that's a great uh that's the
great uh reason for using these the uh
the v sudo utility it actually points
out logical and uh and syntax errors
so we'll save this now and we'll exit
and what we'll do is we'll now switch
into the user lexis and um
i'll go here and you can see that now if
i type in apt-get update you can see
that we can run this command but it
still requires administrative privileges
or root privileges so if we pre-pend it
with root or sorry sudo
if we say sudo and we hit up and we just
enter the password you can see that
we're able to run the command however if
we wanted to display the um we say cat
etsy shadow
uh
cat etsy shadow is going to tell you
these alexis is not allowed to execute
cat etsy shadow with you know root
privileges so again we can say cat
hc password here that works because it
doesn't require root privileges and we
are pretty much allowed to view the
contents of this file
all right so that's how to apply
permissions based on a user all right
now i can also change this up and we can
use the the example of the group here so
we can just go back into the user admin
and
just enter the password here and again
we'll say sudo
vsudo and we'll get into this so we'll
comment this uh you know user privilege
specification entry and we can enter our
group anywhere here we can just add a
comment if we wanted to
specification
um developer group
we can just say developer group and then
we say
when adding a group we prepend it with
the the modulus sign and then we say we
specify the name of the group so we say
developers and then after this we
specify the permissions here so again we
can say all
all hosts and then we'll say all users
of all groups that's because we need a
sudo that's very important we need the
ability to access all the groups so
again we can all we can always limit it
to
uh all users and then the admin group if
we wanted to but again we say all
and then instead of all commands we say
user bin
we can say apt user pin
sorry user bin apt get update uh sorry
apt-get sorry not update
um so we can save this and if we exit
you can see we have no syntax errors so
again back to alexis here
and i will enter the password
and uh yeah so now we can say sudo apt
uh
get update and that works fine uh for
some reason
uh not allowed to execute uh let me just
check this right now uh yeah it's part
of the developers group uh let me just
go back into the admin group here oh
sorry into the admin user
and uh let's see what the issue is
what's the issue is with the
specification of uh
of permissions here um
so
what i'll do is um let's see what can be
this shouldn't be causing any issues uh
let's try apt and let's just see whether
this works i'll just say
i have to update that that works fine
um i believe you need to add yeah you
need to separate the commands and it
would be wise to use command command
aliases so yeah i i simply forgot about
that sorry about that guys um so so that
will work fine so again if we say sudo
cat etsy shadow
for example
yeah because we wanted to view it you
can see it again it restricts us to
running uh only the apt update utility
or running the app utility here so that
is how to you know sort of segregate
permissions based on a user whether you
want to specify the permissions you know
on a user to use a basis
or how to specify the permissions on a
you know in in regards to adding users
to a group and then applying them that
way sort of blanketing the users that
way so again it's all about
you know what philosophy you are you
adapt to and if you're a system
administrator it'll also depend on the
use case and the use you usage scenario
in which your server is being deployed
in
we're going to be talking about
networking uh in the command line all
right so let's get started now
um if you pretty much watched any of my
older videos where we were working with
networking within the linux terminal you
know that i would typically use the
ifconfig utility however
you know the standard has changed now
and what we have to use or what is the
preferred method of getting information
and interacting with various network
interfaces is by using the ip command
right so the ip
utility allows you to you know show
manipulate routing network devices
interfaces and tunnels etc
all right so let's get started by first
of all um understanding how to display
your current uh routing table so again
we can do that by typing in ip route
show and that's very simple so ip route
show and this will show you your current
uh routing table so you can see this is
my uh this is uh this is currently my
router's ip address or my gateway uh
this is my interface name here and this
is the source ip which is my ip address
so that gives you an idea of uh of your
ip routing table uh currently
now again you can take a look at uh we
can grip route here and uh in the man
pages and you can take a look at all the
options you have available for you um so
you can pretty much change the route if
you want to do but of course that's
beyond the scope of this tutorial i'm
simply showing you how to find
information that's very useful if you
want to display your current ip address
we type in
ipaddr and we hit enter and this gives
you your two interfaces so we have local
this is a loop back so this is you know
for your local host
uh and you then have your ethernet in my
case my ethernet adapter which has the
interface name enp2so
you can see that it has an ip of
192.168.1.1
and you have the uh the entire uh
the entire network range there
um you also have your your ipv6 ip
address here that is required and of
course you have your mac address so very
similar to ifconfig um so if we
if we take a look at ifconfig which is a
perfectly great uh tool that you can use
and so you know you can use it if i type
in i have config
we can take a look at the man pages here
just so i can show you the flexibility
so again uh you can play around with all
the options that are available but
pretty much the simple way of going
about it would be to simply display your
current um so if i say ifconfig
and i'm only looking for my
i can say inets if i'm only looking for
my ipv4 address or my inet addresses you
can see that i can easily just print
them out and i also have my net mask so
a very organized way of taking a look at
your your interfaces and your ip
addresses as well
right now i'm still to make a video on
on managing services
and processes with linux but uh
essentially working with your network
manager we can also take a look at dhcp
because that would be quite important so
if you are running this on wi-fi or you
are using a wireless adapter or even an
ethernet where you don't have static ip
distribution
or resolution what we can do is if we
say what is dhclient um and we can just
hit enter you can see that uh if we type
in dh client and we hit enter you can
see that it doesn't give us any
any options here so if we take a look at
the options that we available to use we
can pretty much um
let's take a look at the man pages
because this is a bit better way of
actually utilizing it so again we can
use the dhcp v4 protocol to obtain
a new ipv4 address but in my case i i
have my ip statically uh assigned here
so that would not be a wise thing to do
but if i wanted to restart my network
manager uh again i'll be making a an
individual video on this so you don't
have to worry so you can use sudo
service
network
network manager
um
restart and i can hit enter or i can use
system d so i can say sudo system
control
uh we can say restart we say network
let me just see network we're looking
for the network manager here so if i let
me just tab and see what we have we're
looking for the network manager.service
which is right over here so i can
execute this and that will essentially
restart it now again as i said if you're
not familiar with processes don't worry
we'll be covering it in the next set of
videos as we wind up this series
but that's pretty much how to restart
your network adapter if you're having
any issues and you can sort of work with
that now let's talk about netstat
because again that's quite an important
tool and i haven't i have a an
independent video on how to use netstat
if you are interested in it so again we
can say netstat and we hit enter say
print network connections routing tables
uh et cetera et cetera so i'll just go
i'll just go over the most common
options you can use and this essentially
allows you to understand what uh what
services ports uh you have running
listening and are you are connected to
so for example
if i wanted to display the route i would
say net stat and i would say r and that
gives me my routing table so we have the
destination uh the gateway the gen mask
flags and the interface here
so in all cases we're working with my uh
with my ethernet interface here so you
can see that
for the default gateway uh we have it
right over here the destination and of
course the gen mask so again you can get
very good information from this now if
we wanted to take a look at all the tcp
connections that we have we can say net
stat and we use t and that gives us all
the tcp connections on uh that we are
currently connected to or listening
for on our system so you can see that uh
we have the protocol which is very
important this is this is uh uniquely
going to be tcp
uh the local address the foreign address
the port it gives you and the state
which i'll get to in a second
um so you can pretty you can also grab
information from this so again you can
say grip and if i had the ssh
uh port open uh i would hit i'll say
grep 22 for example and uh you pretty
much gives you results based on
the actual string of characters in this
case it's not giving us anything new but
if all to say
um let's say
sudo
sudo
service ssh
start now hit enter
and if we try and grip this now uh we
don't get anything so let's uh let's
take a look at how to find a listening
ports so or listening socket so we can
say netstat
l and we hit enter and you can see
there's quite a bit of listening uh of
stock of sockets that are currently
listening for
uh
for actual connection so in our case you
can see we have the ssh port here
and we can pretty much grip
with these particular services um and
you can sort of work with that if you
want to
uh talking about udp only we can again
that's very simple so that's that if i
wanted listening tcp connections i would
say um for example lt and hit enter and
that will only display the listening tcp
connections if i wanted listening udp
connections i would
type in lu and again that gives us all
the listening udp connections
um if we want to display the the actual
processor processes and the process ids
we can say netstat
p and we hit enter
and what we can do is we can say ltp
so ltp and we're looking for grip ssh
and we hit enter it again tells you uh
that we have ssh running in or you can
go through this all over again so let me
just clear this out
so if we display the results here um you
can see that
it gives you all the information that
you're looking for uh so if we get rid
of this and we also have p it gives you
the various process ids
uh so if we let's just take a look at
the table right at the top here that
pretty much prints it all
uh you can see we have the pid right
over here and we can sort of grip
through that if we wanted to
so that's uh using um netdiscover
netstat uh we're not talking about net
discover yet but again you can check out
our independent video on that and allows
you to check various connections that
you have open and you know running
either established or listening on your
system they could be for both a tcp and
udp
now let's talk about net discover now
net discover does not come pre-installed
with any linux distribution as far as
i'm concerned apart from the pen testing
uh or offensive distribution so again we
can simply just say what is netstat
and you can pretty much um well no not
nets that net discover
um i believe this is uh its cover like
so and we hit enter and it's an active
passive uh erp reconnaissance tool
and so what this means is it allows you
to essentially scan your network for uh
for other devices or hosts that are
currently connected to your network
whether they be uh wi-fi enabled devices
or connected to your uh to your network
via ethernet or to your switch um so
again to install it you can use any of
the package managers you're comfortable
with and we simply type in net discover
and we hit enter so do have to get
installed sorry
and we hit enter and you can see already
have it installed so using it requires
root privileges so we say sudo
net discover
and then we specify the interface that
we want to use so we can see enp2s0
and hit enter and as you can see it will
start scanning and it's doing this
through arp or the address resolution
protocol so arp
request and response packets so again
it's sending various arp requests
to you know all ips on the network and
then the responses give us the results
that uh that actually prove that whether
we have a device or not so you can see
i currently have the my router which is
running uh this is the default gateway
and then i also have another device
running here
let's see if we have any other devices
and we'll just wait for it to continue
scanning
so i'll just wait for this to continue
scanning i think i have multiple other
devices this is pretty much going to be
my windows device if i bring up
a mobile device here let's see if that
actually
comes up
and i'll try and load up a website here
i actually don't have my phone on me but
in any case this essentially gives you
all
it essentially gives you all devices on
your network and that's a great way of
monitoring your network and viewing what
devices you have so again it gives you
the ip their mac address and their mac
vendor so again it gives you an
information about what device you're
dealing with so in this case tp-link and
then hot high precision which is pretty
much a network adapter and once you're
done you just hit ctrl c and that will
terminate the process right over there
all right now to end up at or to end
this video
let's talk about a dns which a lot of
people actually ask me about so your dns
information
or your name servers rather are going to
be stored in your resolve.com file so
again sudo
uh sudo and we'll use vim etsy and we're
looking for the resolve uh
resolve dot com file and we hit enter
you can see that this uh this file is
managed uh by the system they resolved
uh and we can i'll actually show you how
to use that utility shortly um
so this is a dynamic result or
configuration file for connecting local
clients to the internal dns stub
resolver of systemd so again it tells
you that this is going through systemd
and this is more of a dynamic uh of a
dynamic file that is generated
dynamically
and again it is just for connecting
local clients to the internal dns dns
resolver with systemd resolved um and
i'll be talking about services as i said
later on but many people edit this which
will work temporarily uh however if you
do want to take a look at systemd
resolve that's extremely simple so
what you could do if you want to use
this manually is uh we would actually
just add another one here so i can say
name server and then i'll say for
example go the google name server eight
eight eight eight
and uh i can use that if i want to but
in our case we're not gonna we're not
gonna have any changes here so we'll
just exit so
you can actually check the status of
system d resolve so we can say uh system
b
uh resolve sorry resolve and we say
status
and we hit enter and again that gives
you uh the various dns information that
you're looking for so we can print out
so you can see the dns servers that we
currently have set
are going to be the google dns server
and this is going through your uh your
actual your router or your main gateway
so it would be advisable to switch uh
you know to any dns server that you want
to do or that you want to use on your
main router
so you can see that it uses the default
one that is your default gateway ip here
and the google
the google dns server that i have set
here and that was simply for the
demonstration purposes in this video so
that's how to system they resolve
um now when talking about your hosts
file this essentially allows you to
manage your various hosts and you can
use this uh you know for ad blocking
uh or yeah you can use it for ad
blocking if you want to so for example
uh we can say sudo
vim and we say etsy and we say host and
we hit enter and you can see uh for
example where we have uh defined uh the
local host or the loopback
uh you know
127.0.0.1 is our localhost and then the
current host here which is alexis
workstation is
127.0.1.1 so i could also change that to
any other ipa i want
so if you're going to block an ad what
you typically do is you put an invalid
ip address here so i could say zero zero
zero zero
uh and i could sort of block a website
here like for example
i could say google.com
which is not a smart thing to do but in
any case uh we can write those changes
and exit and then if i say sudo system
control
we say restart network
manager i believe
network manager dot service
um so we will just let me just try and
complete this for some reason it isn't
displaying this system
system control
network manager.service
and we want to use this so we want to
restart the network manager and i'll
actually show you this to you right now
um so if we try and open up a firefox
instance here and we say google.com and
we hit enter you can see
uh it pretty much redirects us to the
local host and
that's essentially how to use the hosts
file now i can change the ip to
something i do something else completely
but again many of you have been asking
me how to use the hosts file so that's
pretty much how to use it
and we can get rid of that right now
because i don't want that to be the case
and we can just restart the network
manager one more time
and there we are so we should be good
there all right so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover in regards to
networking and all that is important as
i said we'll be taking a look at
services i will also be taking a look at
ssh and if you are interested in in
exploring tools like netstat and net
discover you can check my independent
videos
in this video we're going to be talking
about how to use store and proxy gains
in conjunction to anonymize your traffic
uh you know through the use of any tool
that you want so both of these tools
don't come pre-installed on you know
standard distributions but you can
pretty much find them on pen testing and
offensive distributions so again what we
need to do is install the tor service
first not the tor browser but the actual
tor service and then secondly we need to
install the proxy chains tool so again
to install the tour service all we need
to do is say sudo
sudo apt you can use whatever package
manager using sudo apt-get install and
it's pretty much going to be just store
that will be the name of the service and
i already have it installed so
again if you just want to check what it
is so you can say what is store and this
is referring to the actual
um due to the actual service so you can
see that what is a second generation
onion router
so if we say man
tor and we hit enter you can see that
door
uh is a connection oriented anonymizing
communication service users i choose a
source routed path through a set of
nodes
uh and negotiate a virtual circuit
through the to the network i think i've
pretty much explained this before in
previous video as to how the tor how tor
works um so we'll be using tor now uh to
start the tour service we can use
systemd or you can also use a service
um so we can say sudo system control and
we say uh we can say start and then we
are looking for tor uh
i think where it is the tor service here
uh i'm not too sure what it is what it's
called so if we say tor
let's check the status here
status store
and you can see that we currently have
it loaded and active so again the tor
service is an anonymizing overlay
network for tcp so if we use netstat
here so we can say netstat
and we can look for listening tcp
connections and we grip for the port
that the door service connects through
which is 1950 and we hit enter you can
see we now have uh you know we are
listening on port 9050 and this is
localhost so that's perfect we can use
this with proxychains all right so now
let's talk about proxychain so again uh
installing proxychains is very simple so
you do upgrade install proxychains uh
sorry um
proxy chains and we enter and i already
have it installed uh before we actually
use it we now need to uh we need to play
around with the configuration file so
that we can tweak the the configuration
to what we want it to be and how we want
it to work so we can say sudo vim hc
proxychains.conf and we hit enter
so again
pretty much i'll go through the settings
that i use so again
we can use http x4 sox5
uh and again we this allows you to
tunnel um or proxy you can you can
essentially tunnel your connections
through a series of proxies and in our
case the proxies are going to be is
going to be tor so with dns that's the
great thing so
uh the options below identify how the
proxy list is treated only one option
should be common uncommented at a time
so
dynamic chains where each connection
will be done via chained proxies all
proxy chained in order as they appear in
the list at least one proxy must be
online to play in the chain i i pretty
much like using the random chain
so you can see that each connection will
be done via random proxy or proxy chain
from the list this option is good to
test your intrusion detection system
because it's constantly changing uh you
know through random proxies but if again
if you want a dynamic chain that's
perfect
uh you can also use the strict chain
this will ensure that uh all connection
are going to be done through a chain
proxy or all proxies will be chained in
the order as they appear in the list so
i like using a random chain so you want
to uncomment this or it will be
commented here so
if i just hit insert here and it'll
pretty much be commented like so and you
want to uncomment this
we then want to take a look at the proxy
dns request so again this will prevent
no leak for dns data this is very
important you want to make sure that's
uncommented and then we want to take a
look at the proxy list format so this
gives you an idea of how to use your
proxy list if you are interested in
using other proxies apart from tor
you can see that we have socks 5 http
sox4 you know in our case the defaults
will be set to door and we want to add
socks 5 as well here so we say socks 5
and we can we remember it's running on
our local host uh sorry 127.0.0.1
uh 1950 and that's of course going to be
um that's going to be socks 5 all right
so we can add any of the other proxies
we want here so again if you're not keen
on using tor you can change this and
we'll write changes and quit from here
so now when using proxy chains you want
to ensure that you have the toss service
started and it's currently running and
then i use the syntax is very simple so
we say proxy chains
and then we specify the tool that we
want to use um so for example
i can say proxy chains are firefox uh or
i can use another tool like ssh or
telnet
or i could use a tool uh maybe let's try
firefox because it's the easiest way to
test this so i say firefox
and then i open this website dns
leaktest.com
and we hit enter and that's going to
start proxy chains for us now given that
it's using door the connection is going
to be much slower than you know a
standard proxy uh of course depending on
what proxy you end up using so we'll
just wait for this to load up and the
dns lictest.com
will tell us what our ip is and secondly
it will tell us
what our dns is so you can see
it gives us information regarding our ip
um for some reason isn't telling us what
country it is so again we can just hit a
standard test this will test our dns to
see if we
are leaking any dns information and of
course dns information is very important
as it can leak your geographical
information so again you can just go
through the test and this will display
whether or not what dns servers you're
currently been using so let's wait for
this and see what results we get there's
a progress bar right over here so you
can see that all are going through um
dns servers in germany and of course you
have their host names and their various
ips so again that's a great because it
was a we were we didn't leak any of our
personal dns information that or the dns
servers we went through but of course
that is also dependent on on you know
dns security something that's out of the
scope of this video
in this video we're going to be talking
about uh process and service management
uh so we're going to be talking about
lots of tools that you can use to uh to
manage processes
and also manage services right so these
this is a very important video pretty
much i think one of the most important
videos in this series because of of the
power that that comes with it so uh
first of all let's let's take a look at
some of the utilities that you can use
uh to to manage system resources and to
view the current processes and you know
just view resource consumption in
regards to the processes that are
consuming the most and consuming the
least
now by default all linux systems come
with a utility called top right and you
can pretty much get some information
about it by using uh the what is command
so again it tells us that top displays
linux processes so you can hit top and
again as you can see this gives you
information regarding uh your your
system resources the consumption and the
various processes that are running the
the owner of the processes in terms of
the user so you have your process id
very important there that can be used to
manage the process either to kill it
uh or to stop it you then have the user
here that it belongs to
you then have the cpu and memory
consumption
uh the time
and the command itself so again you can
essentially use this to manage all your
processes however the a better utility
custom utility that you can install by
with with whatever the package manager
using
and that is the h-top utility so again
we can install it we can install it here
i already have it installed so again we
can clear this and say what is h-top you
can see that this is an interactive
process viewer so if we open up htop uh
you can see that first of all it gives
you your processor usage
in regards to how many cores you have so
i have six scores here and it gives you
the utilization in terms of percentage
you then have your memory usage so it
gives you a total usage i have about 16
gigs here and i'm currently using six
gig
uh it also tells you your swap usage uh
so i have a swap uh set to about two
gigs uh don't get angry at me and a lot
of people are against swap nowadays
it gives you the amount of tasks
the amount running the load average and
the uptime of your system so very useful
information it also sorts it out it
sorts the information out uh you know
similar to what we add so we have the
process id and you can sort that out uh
chronologically so you can say you can
just click on it and it loads it up from
the first process with the process id of
one you then have the user so you can
again switch from all the user uh the
user accounts that uh that these
processes are running under
you then have your cpu usage so if i
click on cpu that displays uh the the
process that is currently using the most
uh cpu usage uh again i can click on
memory and it tells us that google
chrome is using the most memory that's
that's not a surprise
and of course we can just go back to cpu
usage and you can see that obs is
currently running right now which makes
sense as that is using the most cpu
right so uh this is a utility that you
can use to pretty much manage your
processes now before we take a look at
how to use it because this simplifies
the process
let's take a look at uh you know how you
would actually view these uh the
resource consumption like ram usage for
example to v ram ram usage we would
simply type in free
and that again tells you uh if we that
you know we just use the man pages here
you can see that free uh displays
the amount of free and used memory in
the system so again you can display this
uh in regards to uh to to to the output
you want so if we say three h that
prints it out in human uh readable
format so you can see we have total used
free shared
the cash and available and of course
also for your swap so that's uh one of
the quick ways you can view how much ram
you're using
now let's talk about processes right so
processes uh need to be understood as
you need to separate them between you
need to separate processes and services
right so processes
uh are viewed with the ps tool so again
uh ps uh gives you a report uh it gives
you a report of this uh or it
essentially gives you a snapshot of your
current processes that you have running
all right so if i just say ps
this is weird because many users
actually i've pointed this out so why
does it only give you two processes well
you haven't specified any arguments in
regards to what processes you want to
see so what it's going to give you is
it's simply going to display processes
that are in your current shell and you
can see that the tool that it has is the
bash
and the the actual command that you run
so that makes sense now if we want to
display all processes we would simply
say psa ux
and you can view all of this syntax
from the man page which is actually
recommended here i'm using the psd style
or the bsd syntax so again
to see every process on the system using
standard syntax you can use that i'm
using as you can see right over here bst
syntax so i'll continue with that so i
can say ps aux
and i can hit enter alright so this is a
lot of information here this is
essentially giving you a snapshot of all
the processes that you have running on
your system so we can scroll all the way
to the top and again the it's sorted out
into a table with various columns so
again you have the user the process id
and it starts chronologically
but the great thing about tools like
h-stop is it gives you a dynamic view of
of the processors how much they're
consuming on a second by second basis uh
cpu usage memory etc but this is a
snapshot remember so again this can give
you an idea of all the processes that
are currently active however if you want
a dynamic idea of the current system
resource consumption use a utility like
top or h-top this just gives you a
snapshot all right the key thing we're
looking for here is the pid because we
won't talk about managing processes
right so
let's say um i want to start a service
here
so i say sudo system
control
system control i'm going to say start
and i'll say tor i want to start the tor
service here and then i say ps aux i can
also grab the output here and i can say
i'm looking for tor uh so give me all
processes with door right now of course
it's going to give us you know various
other false positives with the the
string of characters t o r and you can
see the inclusion of that within storage
but if we just go to the bottom here uh
you can see we have um
we have the user bin tour uh binary
being used here so that looks
interesting
and yeah so if we take a look at the
process id we can see it has a process
id of 7604 so if we say uh sudo
system
control we say status status store and
we enter um sorry about this guy system
control and we hit we take a look at the
status of the
of the service you can see that it's
active it's loaded and active so if we
want to kill this process all we need to
do is get the process id in this case
it's going to be 7604
and all we need to do is say
we just say kill
and you may want to prepend this with
root privileges or the pseudo command so
we say sudo kill
uh seven six zero four seven six zero
four and we enter and now if we take a
look at the the the tour service you can
see it's still running now the reason i
did this is because you need to
differentiate between a service and a
process because the service will re
reinitiate or re-initialize itself right
so let's take a look at
the let's take a look at all the
processes here and we can take a look at
more realistic options available to us
right so i'll give you an example here
um so let's grip for ssh and we'll say
grep ssh
let's see we have the ssh daemon here
[Music]
which is running as a process id
of
5687 right and
we also have the uh yeah that's pretty
much the one we're looking for we also
have the ssh agent here
so what we can do is we can say um
pseudo here
one nine six nine
and we can also say pseudo kill 56 87
right so we can say 56 87 you kill that
and then we say system
system
control and say
status ssh and we hit enter you can see
that ssh
is currently loaded but inactive dead
right so that's just a simple way of
managing processes now we can do the
same thing
uh with h-stop and i'll show you how to
do this many people actually skip this
but each stop is has a much easier way
of doing this so when you launch h-stop
uh you can pretty much filter through
the results but a great way of searching
for services by their name instead of
using grep is by using the f3 key
after which it will bring up this little
search bar and i can search for things
like door
uh and if i use a space
it pretty much should give me all the
results so let me just do that one more
time so i say tor
and
we can see that the process was closed
but the the service is still running so
let's try another another process here
let's see if we have um
let's see let's actually work with
h-stop i just want to show you this so
if we click on h-stop and it's
highlighted yellow we can actually kill
it by using f9 so if we hit f9 we can
send various signals to this process so
we can say signal quit signal kill so if
we say signal kill that's option nine
and we hit enter
you can see that that will pretty much
kill the process and you can see that it
actually points that up right over here
and
you can see that the output is messed up
and i shouldn't have probably done that
but i wanted to demonstrate the power of
h stop here so if i go into h stop one
more time and now again it's giving us
our dynamic results so we can pretty
much use that same
syntax to manage our services really
easy and many people go over this it's
not just a system resource uh
usage
utility to actually display how much uh
you know resources you're consuming it
can actually allow you to interact with
your services or your processors quite
well so
again i can search for any process right
over here with name or i can
again i can work with the the resource
consumption so again i can highlight
resource consumption here uh memory
consumption et cetera et cetera right
now let's talk about service management
with system d right because i also want
to cover uh system v as well system v
service management but
now the norm is increasingly becoming
system d so it's great to to actually
know how to use this so
if we say man system
control this is the utility that allows
us to control um
so you can see control the systemd
system and service manager so i'll show
you how to use it so if we want to list
all the active services which are going
to be a lot we can say system
uh control and we hit enter and you can
see that we can you know we can move
down with the uh your your directional
keys
and this gives you an idea of all the
services that you have running and once
you have once you're done we have about
uh 230 lines here and they keep on going
as as the more you you actually go down
so uh 269 loaded units um it gives you
all information regards to all the
services you have running so if we quit
we can also prep so if we grep here we
say grab
ssh and we hit enter so we have no ssh
service running so if we if we want to
start a service like the ssh service
what i can do is i can say
system control
system control i say start and then i
i can you know then play around with
with what i want to do so i can say
um i can say
start and then the name of the service
so i can say ssh and then i can use the
tab auto completion here so again you
can see that we have the ssh socket and
the ssh service so if i wanted to start
the ssh service uh just give it a few
seconds it does take a while to load
this if i use tab auto completion too
much so if i say
system control uh start ssh service and
i hit enter it's gonna ask me for my uh
for my password and it's gonna this
because it requires root privileges
so uh that has started the ssh service
now we can again uh confirm this uh with
you know we can say uh lt here and uh
you can see we have ssh running
right over here so again we can check
the status of the pros of this actual
service by running uh sudo system
control and we can say status
ssh dot service here and we enter
and there we are so you can see it tells
us that the ssh service this is using
open ssh so it tells us it's loaded and
active which means it you can actually
use it and it gives you information
about it so the log of events so again
started uh ssh listening on port 22
listening on localhost port 22 starting
the openssh openbsd secure shell server
and it gives you the various timestamps
right so
that's how to pretty much interact uh to
how to start and monitor the status of a
service if you're having issues with it
right now if i wanted to disable it or
to stop it i could say um i could just
i can say stop
uh and i can say ssh dot service and i
hit enter and that will stop the
sorry let me just enter my password here
that will stop the service
if i check the status you can see that
it's loaded but inactive and dead now a
lot of people ask me how do i run
particular services on system startup
and you can easily do that with systemd
so i can say sudo system let's say i
wanted to enable the ssh service every
time i boot up which is useful
so i can say system control
[Music]
and then i would say enable but first i
need to check if it's already enabled so
i can say is enabled
and then say ssh dot service and that
will tell me if uh it is currently
enabled to
do to be run on system startup you can
see tells us that it's currently
disabled which is great
uh if i check the synergy service i just
want to give you an example a robust
example or hit enter you can see that on
startup yes this service is enabled
that's because i use the synergy service
to you know for my mouse sharing my
mouse and keyboard sharing
system so again that tells me that okay
that's enabled so if we want to enable
ssh what we would say is a pseudosystem
control and we would say enable and say
ssh.service
all right and i hit enter and you can
see it's created the sim link
for us uh in the system d uh directory
here so
uh if you're using um
if you're using system v then you nee
you need to play around with the initial
uh the init scripts uh
and you then need to create a sim link
but this does it automatically for you
so now if we check the uh is enabled if
we check if it's enabled you can see
that now it's enabled if i want to
disable it from running on startup i
would simply say disable
because i don't want ssh running this is
not a server so
i can check it now and we can see it's
disabled all right so
that's pretty much how to manage uh you
know services with system d so that's
how to start stop uh if i want to
restart a service again i can simply say
restart so let me do that right now so
if i say sudo system control i say tor
sorry start
tor i can hit enter that will start the
tour services i want to reload it i can
say reload
all right now i can also um
i can also reload will reload the uh the
configuration if i say restart that will
simply restart the service with the
current configuration so that's a quick
tidbit for you if you you can use reload
here then that will essentially restart
it with the newer configuration so in
case you're wondering so i'll just stop
this service
and i'll just hit enter
and there we are all right so
that is how to manage services now if
you want to uh if we want to reload the
entire the system d daemon what we can
say is sudo system control
uh we're looking for the daemon and we
can say reload and we just hit enter and
that will reload the daemon completely
that's if you're having any issues and
you wanted to reconfigure particular
services
all right
now
let's talk about system v service
management which many of you are
familiar with a system v is essentially
where you say service
the name of the service which could be
door and then we say start
we can say stop
and we can say restart right very very
simple and we can also check the status
so again say service store start
that will ask you know ask me for my
administrator privileges i can say
service store
status hit enter you can see it tells us
active loaded
um and then we can say system a service
store we can say stop and we can hit
enter and that will stop these the door
service and we can also
say restart and again that will simply
restart the tour service there and we
can then stop it one more time so that's
how to use system v very very simple but
in my opinion system d
uh is is the much better alternative to
learn now and it's extremely robust and
very very powerful tool to actually
learn how to use or do low utility
in this video we're going to be talking
about ssh uh how to configure it
securely
uh and then of course we'll talk about
you know how to uh how to securely
transfer files with ssh so let's get
started um first of all with
establishing what ssh client and server
we're going to be using so in our case
we want to be uh we want to be using
openssh which is pretty much the go to
uh the the go to ssh client in server
solution it's completely open source and
it's uh it's one of these uh you know
great services so again that was uh
developed by the bsd team
so um again uh we must first of all
understand the uh the connection type or
the connection model uh with ssh so ssh
is primarily a client server connection
model so that means you need the client
software to
connect to the to the server software in
our case we need to install the openssh
client service or the client package
on our client and of course the openssh
server package on r7 i'll show you that
right now so i'm currently on my client
here which is going to be ubuntu our
remote server is going to be one of my
ubuntu servers uh running on my
virtualization server so
what i'll do is i'll say sudo apt
get install and we say open ssh and we
we're looking for the openssh if we
double tap we can see we're looking for
the openssh client right so i'm gonna
hit enter and uh i already have this
installed right now the openssh client
configuration file is found so if i say
cat hc ssh sorry ssh and this is found
under
it is the ssh config the sshd config
file is for the open ssh server
so you can see i also have my uh my my
public and private keys here as well but
i'll get into that in a second they we
don't need to complicate this right now
so if i take a look at me at my config
file here this is the client config
you can see that um
the options are quite uh straightforward
in regards to what you can enable and
disable so you can specify the port
uh the protocol um
and uh various other bits of
you know configurations here but that's
not the the in within the scope of the
video but i just wanted to get to that
so
uh my remote server is running on um
it's currently running on an ip of
192.168.1.113 so
we already have an admin user on that
system so we'll just say admin and we'll
say 192.168.1.113
all right and i will just enter the
password here for the admin user and
there we are so you can see i'm
currently logged in as the admin user so
the first thing we want to do is we need
to install uh the openssh server so you
say oh apt-get install open ssh
server and the reason i'm doing this
even though i have it installed already
just to show you how one would go about
doing it right
um so hit install already installed
there excellent all right all right all
right now that we have this uh both the
pieces of software installed on the
client and the server
we can talk about uh configuring uh you
know ssh right so pretty much when
dealing with the remote server and
remote authentication the first thing
you need to do is you need to disable
root logins
uh because the root the root user
account is extremely powerful because it
really has no restrictions in regards to
what it can do so that's our first order
of business here and this can be done by
modifying
this can be done by modifying the
openssh
the openssh
configuration file the opensh server
configuration file so if i say sudo vim
hc ssh and we're looking for sshd
uh sshd and we say
sshdconfig and we hit enter so you can
see this is the openbsd openssh
sshdconfig file
and it does you it tells you here this
is a sshd server systemwide
configuration file so the first thing we
want to do is we let's take a look at
some of the various uh configurations
you can set here so you can change the
default port this is great for those of
you who are who want to set up a
honeypot on that exact port like por 22
and then have ssh run on another port
like 2 2 2 0
you can do that as well
you can also change the listen address
if you want to uh the host key names uh
let's talk about uh let's just go down
into logging you can play around with
logging here
uh and i'll talk about logs probably in
another video and here we are we have uh
we have authentication all right so
within authentication you can see we
have an option called permit root login
right and we want to change this to no
right so from yes to no
uh and we we can also play around with
the grace the login grace time so we can
increase this or decrease it based on
the on the time you want to provide
uh we can keep strict modes to yes uh in
regards to the max authentication tries
we can change this to four although i'll
be making a separate video where i'll be
showing you how to set up ssh brute
force protection the max sessions i want
are going to be three public key
authentication
uh yes uh let's go all the way down now
um
and we are primarily looking for
password authentication so we'll talk
about this when we're going to be
setting up ssh keys so for now we've
we've essentially disabled uh where
we've disabled the root logins so if i
just save the the files here now when
whenever you've made changes to the uh
to the open sh server configuration file
we need to restart uh the open ssh
server so to do this again we'll use
systemd so say system
and we say
restart
sshd sshd service remember this is the
sshd daemon or the openssh server and we
hit enter
all right so now pretty much if we just
open up a new tab on my client and i try
and log into the root user account i
would say ssh root and i would say 192
168.1.113
and hit enter right and i enter the
password for the root user
and
you'll see pretty much that we will not
be able to do it so
uh that is pretty much uh going to block
any logins to this uh to this particular
account now the other thing we we want
to do is we want to disable or we want
to lock
the password for the
we want to lock the password for the
root account this will ensure that
even though
a person or an attacker may have
the password the legitimate password
they can get through it through another
user account because remember remember
if if a user gets access to the admin
account via ssh they can easily switch
to the root user account so we also have
to disable you know the password login
here and this will pretty much lock the
account unless we have the privileges to
actually change the password manually
and to unlock it but it's a great way of
of you know
protecting yourself from script kiddies
so
what we can do is we can say um we can
use the password command and say
password uh l and we specify the account
we or
the the account whose password we want
to lock and we hit enter uh we need uh
pseudo privileges here so you say sudo
hit enter and the password expiry
information has changed so you can say
sudo
password and then status
i believe it's status what options can
we specify here
root uh
wait enter no we do not want to enter a
new password so we can just do this one
more time here so you can see that i can
actually change the password but let me
lock it
um
root where is the status how do we check
the status oh yeah there is a capital s
so if we hit enter you can see that the
password is now going to be locked now
uh the second step would be to disable
password authentication and to use ssh
keys which is exactly what i'm going to
show you right now
so that will pretty much ensure that
you're protected from brute force
attacks because you're pretty much
ensuring that you cannot log into this
ssh server
without an ssh key right so
uh what we'll do is we will create a new
ssh key here and this is very this is
very easy to do so uh first of all uh we
need to uh we need to establish
uh what user account we're going to be
you know pretty much be using we've
already locked out the root account
and once we set up the ssh keys we'll be
pretty much logging into the admin user
account and the asset the ssh keys
or the ssh key based authentication will
only allow us to to access the admin
account
after which we will we will modify the
uh the openssh server configuration file
to disable
uh password authentication so what we'll
do is we'll say um
ssh keygen
um
there we are t rsa and we hit enter and
it's going to ask us for
uh it's going to say generating public
private
rsa key pair enter the file in which to
save the key so we'll say
home oil just leave it in this directory
hit enter we can enter a passphrase
that's always recommended i'll enter
password is here that will also add an
additional level of security to your ssh
key because remember the ssh private key
has to be kept secret so
we can see that the keys have been
copied into a home alexis and ssh
directory here so
pretty much what we can do now
is uh if we change our directory into
the ssh directory here you can see that
we have the public and private keys
right over here so what we need to do
now is we need to copy the uh the public
key onto the server so let me just
explain how ssh works really quickly how
the authentication works
so you store your public key on your on
the server and you have your private key
uh with you and the private key is the
most important as it's the
it's pretty much the key that will allow
you to authenticate successfully with
the server so you need to keep it secure
and backed up in the event you lose it
you lose access to the server that's
very important right
so essentially what what's going to
happen here
is your private key is used for
encryption right so your server the ssh
server will use your it will send a
random string of data to you the ssh
client uh after which the ssh client
will encrypt that a random string of
data with the private key and send the
encrypted data
uh to the server the server will then
use your public key to decrypt it and if
it then matches and you know so on and
so forth i'll explain that in a second
so
what we can do now is we need to copy
this uh so we say ssh
copy
id and we specify uh the the server so
we say
192.168.1.113 and we hit enter
it's going to ask you you can see it's
asking for the user alexis but we don't
want to do this remember because we want
to use the uh the user admin so we're
going to say admin and we're gonna hit
enter it's gonna ask for admins password
like so and uh
you can see after we've entered the
password it's gonna ask us for the it's
gonna tell us the number of keys added
is one
and we can now try try login to the
machine with ssh admin and we will
essentially not have uh we will not need
to use passwords but before we do that
we need to disable password
authentication with ssh so to do this
again we say sudo vim and i'm back on
the server now ssh
and we say sshd config and we hit enter
and
we'll go all the way to the bottom here
uh am i in the right configuration file
i believe so
yes we are i believe uh your possible
authentication right over here
and we will change this to no so this
will
essentially disable the ability for you
to log in to this or to this remote
server via ssh with passwords so the
only way you can login
is going to be through ssh keys so now i
can
write changes and exits here and we'll
restart the
ssh server
service or the sshd service we enter and
that's going to restart it for us orange
so now if we exit
we can essentially say ssh
admin
at 182
168.1.113.8 enter and it's going to ask
me for the passphrase for the for the
private key and we're going to unlock
and there we are we now have access
right now some of you might be saying
well uh you have the private key what if
the location is different so let me just
show you this right now so i'll go into
my ssh directory here
and uh
just list all the files and i'll say
i'll move the um
this is sorry sorry about that let me
just go to my local directory here or i
can actually just log out
so cd ssh
and what i'll do is i'll move the
private key so i'll say move id
rsa to uh
sorry to my desktop and i'll hit enter
and now if i try and log in so i say ssh
uh admin
sorry uh
states
enter you can see it logs in just fine
however if if i didn't know the location
what i would say is for example let me
just exit i would say for example if i
was logged in on another computer
i would then say uh so again let me just
go on to my desktop here
if i wanted to specify a private key for
logging in i would say ssh i and then i
would say id rsa and then i say admin at
192.168.1.1138 enter and typically what
you want to do is you want to ensure
that your private key has permissions
you want to ensure that it can only be
read
by the current user and not by the group
or all other users on the system so a
great precaution or a great way of doing
this is saying chmod 400
id rsa and that will essentially protect
your private key right so that is
essentially how to you know set up ssh
uh and how to copy your how to set up
key based authentication how to copy
your ssh keys onto the server
and we cannot talk about you know
copying remote files or copying you know
files remotely with ssh so again to do
this is very simple what i'll do is i'll
just create a file let's say touch test
dot ext and i'll cat fc uh password into
the test.txt file here and what let's
say i wanted to copy this test.txt file
into the ssh server uh what i would do
is i would use the scp utility so the
scp is again secure copy so i would say
scp and then i would specify the file so
i'll say touch
uh sorry test test.txt and then i would
spare out specify the credentials so it
say admin 192.168.1.11
and then i'll specify the location i
want to save it in so i say home admin
uh this is on the remote server by the
way so home uh i can't seem to write
admin today for some reason and i'll
essentially hit enter and you can see
that it actually copied quite quickly so
now if we try and log in so we say ssh
one one three uh
three and eight enter and we list the
files within the home directory for
admin you can see that we have the
test.txt file and if i catch the content
here it's the
it's the password information for the uh
for my client uh right over here which
is running ubuntu and you can see my
user accounts
there so that is pretty much how to use
ssh how to set it up how to set up
authentication how to protect uh your
root user account how to copy files
securely how to set up key based
authentication so i hope that was
comprehensive enough
so this video is going to be focused on
essentially getting you to fully learn
and of course utilize curl to its
maximum potential and i'm going to be
covering as many commands as i possibly
can now that being said curl has a lot
of functionality that you need to
explore on your own as well but i'll be
covering some of the most important bits
of functionality that it does offer to a
normal user or a power user as well
so uh without any further ado let's get
started so for those of you who have
never heard of curl curl is essentially
a utility that allows you to transfer
data to or from a network server using
one of the supported protocols now the
protocols that it does support are http
https ftp
ftps you also have your sftp you have
tftp telnet et cetera et cetera now
there are various other
protocols that it does support in
addition to the ones i've just mentioned
uh but i will get into that later
now the great thing about curl is that
it is a multi-platform tool which means
uh it works on linux uh mac os and
windows now i'm gonna be covering how to
use it on linux but of course the
commands are pretty much the same now in
regards to installing uh installing curl
it as far as i know it comes
pre-installed with most akia linux
distributions uh but if you want to
install it whether or not using the
aptitude package manager you can use the
sudo apt-get install curl command and if
you are if you're using an archbase
distribution you can use the pacman s
command to install it and the the name
of the package is curl all right if you
are using a mac os installation or mac
os as your operating system you can use
the brew install command so that is brew
install and curl all right and that's
pretty much uh simple right over there
with windows you need to download an
executable or a bin file if i'm not
wrong and you need to save it in your
windows directory and of course from
that you can directly launch it from
your command prompt
that being said let's get started now
curl as i mentioned comes pre-installed
with most linux distributions so let me
just clear the terminal here and i'll
maximize it so we can see what's going
on
all right so the basic syntax is as
follows but before we do that let's open
up the help menu you can explore the
help menu if you are if you're really
looking for a bit more functionality or
you're looking for specific functions as
you can see it's a very comprehensive
tool and i'm primarily going to be
covering uh the basic commands that you
that allow you to utilize it quite well
uh that being said many people ask me
how i personally learn about a command
that or a tool that i'm not familiar
with i personally use the man or the
manual for each of these tools so the
manual contains a very very good
description of of all the bits of
functionality in regards to a tool uh
and all linux tools pretty much uh come
with a manual and the manual is
extremely useful so if you you want to
check them out go ahead and do it i
really really recommend it when learning
how to uh how to use a tool
all right so let's talk about the basic
queries you can perform with curl all
right so when i talk about interacting
with the various protocols this
particular video is going to be focused
on http and https i know there is
ftp functionality but i'm not going to
be getting into that because that's more
that's where things sort of get a bit
different but for now let's focus on
those two protocols all right so when
performing a basic query of a url uh you
essentially type in curl and then the
url so for example if i type in
hsploit.com here
and hit enter what will happen is this
will essentially fetch the content of
the specified url so for example i've
hit curl https hsplugged.com and it will
essentially return to me the content of
the entire web page now you might be
wondering well how can we verify this
and that's where we get into essentially
saving your output into a file or
downloading files so i can say for
example curl and if i want to output the
uh the output of this command or the
contents of this query i can say i can
use the lowercase o and i can then say i
specify the directory i want to save it
in so home alexis desktop
and i'll just uh sorry that is desk that
is desktop and i'll just call it uh
hsploit
dot html and after that i'll type in
hsflight.com
right over here that is the url now it's
very important to specify
uh the protocol that you're using so for
example if a website is http you won't
need to specify to get it if it is using
the https protocol it is very important
but i'll get into redirection in a
second so
https.com and we hit enter and it's
going to give you this little status
right over here essentially giving you
an update as to what is the current
status of the entire process here now
for some reason it's taking quite a
while now
but we'll wait for it to complete and
there we are so
let me explain a bit of the uh the the
structure of this little status menu or
table here so for example you have the
total amount to be downloaded uh the
amount received the average download
speed the upload speed the the total
time are the time spent and the time
left and uh right now if we cat
uh the the hs flight dot um well
actually if we need to go into our
desktop here uh so if we capped
hsploit.html here you can see the entire
contents now if we open that up here if
i open that up with uh with chrome for
example let me just open this up where
is google chrome
um
where is google chrome here there we are
google chrome if i just open that up
here in a web page you can see that
pretty much it has all the content of my
website so each exploit.com and it's
pretty cool that it does save the entire
contents of the html file here now of
course this is going to um this is going
to leave out
extra bits of files in regards to the
the web page but this is a great way of
saving the contents of a query now that
could be for any other protocol it not
it does not necessarily need to be for
the http or the https protocols all
right now when we talk about downloading
files
that is pretty much how it goes for a
web page or for a query so let me just
remove the hsp.html mind you i could
have saved it as a txt file i simply i'm
saving it so that i can use it at a
later time now you can also use curl to
download files from the web which is
really really awesome and that's
primarily why i have the ubuntu page
open here because i want an example to
use so for example if i wanted to
download the ubuntu iso
i go to the download page and i select
the air version 18.4
18.04 lts
and it's going to start the download so
if i just going to show all downloads
here and let me just copy the link here
the download link so i can go into curl
and i can say for example
i can give the file name a new name or i
can just download it directly so let me
explain the two ways of doing it so for
example i can say curl
i can output the uh i cannot i can say
download this file as ubuntu
iso
dot iso sorry iso and then i i paste in
the the download link and what that is
going to do is that it's going to
download the file and save it as ubuntu
iso dot iso now the extension is very
important because if you get that wrong
it's going to save it as a different
file type all right so if i enter you
can see it's going to start the download
and there we are we can see that the
total amount to be downloaded is one uh
194 megabytes which is about 1.9
gigabytes and you have the received the
download speed the average download
speed and the current download speed
right over here the time left etc etc
now you can see that my internet speed
is pretty bad right now but that's
primarily because i am updating one of
my systems so i do apologize for that so
if we check the desktop you can see we
have the ubuntu iso over here which does
prove that it does work all right now
the other way of doing it
let me just remove the ubuntu iso.iso
file there the other way of doing it is
by downloading it with its original file
name which is specified on the on the
web server so
to do that i simply type in curl and i
use the capital o and i paste in the
download link and hit enter and that is
going to download the file with its
original download name so you can see
ubuntu 18.04.2
uh desktop amd 64-bit dot iso or md64
dot iso all right so that is
pretty much how to download files and
now that i've explained that
we cannot talk about redirects because
redirects are extremely important so
if i just get rid of ubuntu here so if a
website is redirecting to another url
it's very important that you know how to
specify this to curl and why is that
important so in many cases redirects may
be set up and of course that is
specified by the http
300 request or the it could be any 300
requests mostly theo one or three or
three
and it's very important that you know
how to specify this with call now the hd
the http protocol syntax is very
important in curl and you can do this by
using the l command or the capital l
command sorry so for example
if my website was uh if the
urlhsflight.com
was uh so if i say
hsplug.com
was redirecting to another url to
another url and i wanted to specify this
to curl i would use the l command now i
know that my website is not and a great
way of demonstrating this is by using uh
the so for example if i say curl
http
hslight.com
right over here and hit enter and we'll
give that a few seconds here and i'll
explain what's happening in a second so
that you can see the importance of
specifying uh the l parameter if there
is a redirect so you can see i got no
result and that's because curl is going
to http and that's the importance of
protocols with curl you need to specify
the correct protocol irregardless of
whether or not you're using ftp
http https so my website is https now my
website by default will redirect however
you need to specify that with curl i do
apologize for that and let me just clear
the notifications here
so again i i as i mentioned you need to
specify this with girls so i can say
curl and i use the l command over here
and then i specify http
uh and then i say hsplight.com here
right over here and hit enter
and that will essentially redirect me to
the appropriate webpage and
as you can see right over here we get
the entire contents of the
hsp.com website or html file rather so
that is how to do essentially how to
work around um how to work around
redirects
all right now another bit of important
another important command sorry is the
querying response headers so you can
also view and analyze the response
headers being sent by a particular web
server
and this can help in web assessment so
for example if i wanted to query the
response uh the response headers i'm
being sent back by the web server i can
say curl
capital i and i can say
https
hs plate.com
and i can just hit enter and what's
going to happen here is it will give it
a few seconds this is going to depend on
uh varyingly depending on your on your
particular web server so you can see it
gives us the protocol we have cookies
here uh we have the php version so we're
getting important information now uh
looks like we have some wordpress json
files here if i delivered by the cdn or
the content delivery network
uh let's look at some important cookies
here that might give us a bit of
information in regards to the website so
an important bit of information here and
of course i'm using this as an example
is the dwqa
and this is my question and answer
plugin that i use and you can see that
it has an anonymous cookie that's being
set here and that can give you
information as to a bit more of how the
web application is working so that is
how to query the response that is being
sent by the server and of course you can
see right over here this is a cloudflare
server and we have the cfra which is the
cloudflare array
that essentially uh uh
is telling cloudflare uh what uh it's
giving information to cloudflare about
the particular client that is accessing
the web server all right now that is
very interesting however it really gets
interesting because girl can also do a
really cool thing it can also allow you
to view the request headers and the
connection details so you can view the
tls handshake et cetera et cetera so if
i say curl
v and i say curl v
https
and they say exploit.com here and hit
enter you can see that we can view the
entire tls and shake which is really
really unique and awesome so
let me just see if i can figure uh which
is wait which is right over here so
there we are we can see the the initial
connection here
uh we i'm particularly looking for the
tls uncheck and right over here we can
see the tls handshake taking place so
you can see that it is successful and
this is a great way of identifying um
problems with the tls uncheck if the
certificate has an issue so for example
we have the client hello the server
hello we then have the encrypted
extensions being exchanged the
certificate is being exchanged and then
verified and then finally the tls
uncheck is completed you can see that we
have the version tls version 1.3 and the
ciphers that are being used or the
encryption being used
all right so you also have information
about these certificates uh expiry date
uh when it was actually registered uh
the issuer all that good stuff so if you
do want to view
uh if you do want to view the connection
details and a bit of an advanced
information or additional information in
regards to the connection you can go
ahead and use the uh the v command
now the last thing that i want to cover
in regards to the http and http hts
protocols is the fact that you can cross
post requests and many people have seen
me using this in ctfs particularly when
i'm essentially brute forcing um
login pages so
uh i can give you an example so if i
wanted to essentially test credentials
on a website and this can really be in
any uh i can be using any parameters i
could be spoofing various cookies all
that good stuff so for example i can say
if i wanted to log in to wordpress site
and i wanted to essentially test various
credentials i can say for example
curl
data and that is the sorry the data that
we're specifying and then in here i
would specify log and this is the
particular syntax for wordpress and the
password would be equal to i can say
password here and then i close the uh
the uh the quotation marks and then i
specify uh the wordpress page here so i
can say
https and you can say
wordpress.com and i can say wordpress
login dot php and that is the login page
right over here and if i hit enter
and i know this you can see that admin
is not a valid username or wordpress.com
etc you get the response so this is a
great way of testing various pieces of
data so you can also play around with
cookies all that good stuff and in this
case we're simply playing around with
the login and the password parameters
here and we specified our own values
now if you do need to to encode the
particular parameters you can also use
burp suite for that so for example
um let's see if i wanted to go um let me
just uh turn intercept on here
if i just went into hsploy.com here so i
just say it it's exploit.com and it's a
wordpress login.php
sorry.php here and i just hit enter and
uh for some reason we're getting stack
uh stack
we're just getting a stack protect here
in any case uh the what i was getting to
if you do want to encrypt your url or
any other parameters you can use the
control plus u key
in this video we're going to be looking
at how to use the uncomplicated firewall
or as it is commonly known as ufw on
linux alright so you might be asking
what exactly is ufw or what is the
uncomplicated firewall if it isn't
already self-explanatory well
ufw or the uncomplicated firewall acts
as an interface to ip tables and is
designed to simplify the process of
configuring a firewall now you also
might be asking well what exactly is
iptables well iptables is an extremely
flexible firewall utility that was built
for linux operating systems now you also
might be asking well why aren't we using
ip tables why are we using ufw as
opposed to ip tables well iptables is a
great tool that offers great
functionality when it comes down to
configuring firewalls however it can be
difficult for beginners to learn how to
use it properly when configuring a
firewall as a result ufw is well suited
for beginners and as a result they can
use they can learn how to use a firewall
or to configure a firewall really really
easily and they can learn about rules
etc they get the the general idea behind
a firewall all right so ufw is a is a
great firewall that is designed to be
run on hosts or servers uh but it's only
doubtful in the extent is in the extent
uh it offers in in terms or in regards
to functionality what i mean by this it
it only goes so far as uh
as allowing you to block or allow
connections to and from uh to and from
the server so incoming and outgoing and
you can also block ip addresses ports
etc and entire an entire subnet
which i'll get into in a second
all right
so the purpose of this video the purpose
of this video is to teach you how to use
ufw and all the comments that you need
to know to get started and to fully
utilize it to its uh due to your
advantage really so this will include
commands such as allowing and blocking
various services by port uh and their
source ip addresses and this video
should be used as a reference so if this
is your first time with ufw you can
definitely find something that you
haven't you that you didn't know in this
video if this is your if you're already
an experienced use of ufw hopefully you
can find something in this video that
you didn't know already alright so
without any further ado let's get
started
so
uh installing ufw is very very simple
now if you are using an ubuntu server or
you're running ubuntu ufw should be
pre-installed on it if it isn't getting
installed on any other distribution is
very very simple use your aptitude
package manager so sudo apt-get install
ufw i already have mine installed so
it'll check for an update if there isn't
an update it's not going to update it
and it's going to give me the results
here all right so once it is installed
we are ready to begin
now the important bits of using ufw are
always knowing its state or its status
all right so currently i have ufw
disabled it is not running and if i
wanted to know that i would simply type
in
sudo
ufw status now it is very important to
precede the ufw command with sudo if
you're not using a root user in my case
i'm using the root user so i don't need
to use the sudo command but in any case
i will use it so that it becomes a good
practice with you and i don't recommend
running efw from the root user but this
is a simple video for demonstration all
right so i'm going to hit enter it's
going to tell you the status of the ufw
or the uncomplicated firewall is
inactive which is great all right now i
can also check an additional i can get
more information from the status command
by typing in verbose which will give me
more information in regards to the rules
that are currently active now as you
guessed it will not display anything
because we haven't set any particular
rules and the if the firewall is
currently not active so nothing really
special there and the last status
command that is very very popular is to
is to show the status the numbered
status so that you have an idea of what
uh what rules are currently running and
their number so that you can terminate
or delete them all right so that's what
what it's there for now of course these
don't make any sense right now because
the the current status of the firewall
is inactive once we activate it or once
it is active we will be able to get a
whole lot more information from them all
right so i'm going to enter again you'll
see it's going to tell you that it is
inactive and that is fine
all right
so let's talk about enabling disabling
and resetting ufw so enabling ufw is
very simple sudo ufw and enable and that
will enable the firewall and it'll give
you the little status over here the
firewall is active and is enabled on
system startup which is excellent so
that it is always active and if you are
running a server that is huge for you
all right so disabling it is very very
simple we simply type in
disable and we hit enter
all right and that will tell you that
the firewall is stopped and disabled on
on system startup
now when i talk about resetting the the
ufw or the uncomplicated firewall this
is in regards to the rules that you
might have set now please do use caution
with the reset command the reset command
is there to to help you out if you have
made a mistake in configuring your
firewall now if you already have a
working firewall and you only want to
delete a particular rule do not use the
reset command because that will reset
your firewall to the default uh to the
default configuration that it came with
pre-installed or installed or the the
configuration it came with installed all
right so if i type in sudo ufw
uh ufw reset that will reset it and
it'll tell you that which is very good
resetting all the rules to the installed
defaults proceed with operation
y or n for yes or no hit yes to reset it
and there you are so there is a small
fyi if in case you wanted to know that
and you've messed up
in this video and you want to reset it
there you are
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to start off we
understanding the default policies uh
for the ufw or the uncomplicated
firewall
all right so
uh the default policies uh for ufw are
as follows uh now before we do that let
me explain something so ufw
uh by default will it will deny all
incoming connections but will allow all
outgoing connections so what is
happening here is sudo ufw
and you can you can always use this to
to restore it to its default policies so
sudo ufw
default
deny
incoming
all right so that is the default uh that
is the default connection for incoming
or the default connection status for all
incoming connections so by default ufw
will deny all incoming connections and
it will
it will allow
all outgoing connections
so it will allow all default outgoing
connections and of course you can change
this to whatever you want if you want
incoming connections to be allowed while
the firewall is active then you can also
do that as well so i can say default
allow
incoming all right which is not the
smartest thing to do if you're running
this on a server you want to manage what
connections are incoming
in case your your server is being
attacked but that is a very very
different story and hopefully i'll make
a video on that later on in configuring
a server for security
in this case we'll just leave them to
its defaults all right which are are
going to be set by default you don't
need to set them i'm simply explaining
to you how to do it and how to change
them if you want to change them all
right so this gate is great for normal
systems uh but when it comes down to
servers it becomes a little bit
different and you want to be able to
manage the incoming connections in
regards to services and ports and the ip
addresses that are going to be allowed
to connect to your computer or your
server
all right
so what i want to do is
the first thing i want to do is i'm
going to talk to talk about services and
ips all right so if i want to allow an
incoming ssh connection uh how do i do
that well it's very simple so sudo ufw
allow ssh all right and this is going to
allow all ssh connections it's going to
allow in incoming ssh connections all
right which is okay if
as long as you have a private key and
you've properly secured the ssh
connection and and the authentication
all right so i'm going to hit enter it's
going to tell me rule is updated
fantastic you can also do this by typing
in the port so i can say sudo ufw allow
22 and it's going to update uh the rules
accordingly now if i want to if i want
to disable you ssh incoming ssh i can
say sudo ufw deny
ssh all right and i'm going to hit enter
it's going to tell me the rule is
updated which is which is also very very
good and of course you can do that
with the port as well but with services
these are the particular services the
services by the name in which they are
sorted so ssh is going to be known as
ssh and it knows that ssh uses port 22.
all right let's talk about uh working
with port 80 or http connections
so that is what uh unencrypted web
servers use and the connections can be
allowed with the following command so
you can type in sudo ufw
uh allow
allow http and we hit enter it's going
to update the rules and you can also do
it with using uh you can also do it
using the port which is port 80 hit
enter and there you are in my case i'm
going to deny this so i'm going to say
deny http hit enter and we're good again
all right so what i'm going to do is
before we actually continue i'm going to
leave some services running so that when
i enable the firewall you'll be able to
see them when i when i essentially check
the status
all right so i'm going to say
ufw
enable or sorry allow
allow ssh because i want to allow ssh
connections
sorry about that my typing is pretty bad
right now allow ssh there we are
fantastic and we can move on to the next
protocols and services
now talking about https or port 443 that
is again uh what encrypted web servers
use and can be allowed with the
following command so you can type in
sudo
allow https and hit enter and that's
going to allow https connections again
that can be replicated or duplicated
with the port 443 in this case i'm just
going to deny the connection so i'm just
going to https and there we are so the
rules are going to be updated
successfully for ipv4 and ipv6 as well
that is why you have rules updated for
both the protocols over here
all right now if you want to allow both
uh http and https you can do that in
you can do it in one command and that is
done by typing sudo ufw allow and you
can also deny it as well so proto the
protocol is going to be tcp
proto is tcp you can also change that
depending on what protocol you're using
so from any
from any target or you can also use the
ip so from this particular target but
i'll get to that in a second so we're
going to say from any any computer we
are simply going to allow the connection
from any
to any
port
uh to any port and we specify the port
support 80 and 443 hit enter the rules
updated so we can also deny it as well
which is what i'm gonna do because i
don't want that running so deny and
voila all right so that is how to run it
in one command and the the key words
here are going to be the allow and deny
that is the most important bit here all
right if you're talking about ftp that
is again uftp uh sorry um
uh ufw nor am i talking ufw
uh ufw allow ftp or port 21
and that can also be denoted by port 21
tcp hit enter and it's going to uh
because it already exists we can then
say deny
and you need to specify with ftp that
we're using it in tcp so deny rules
updated successfully and that is how to
configure or enable and disable ftp
connections
all right now let's move on to ip
addresses now before we actually move on
to ip addresses four services this is
all done through the port and also
through the name so if you're running
pop3 a pop3 mail server you can also do
it as well if you're running mysql i can
say ufw
allow
3306 that is a mysql a database and i'm
just going to deny it or i'll leave that
running so that we can also check the
status i don't have a mysql server
running on this computer but that's how
you one would do it so uh in most cases
you want to deny connections to your ad
to your
to your mysql database so in this case
i'm going to say 3306 deny any
connections to that particular port and
of course i can specify the eyepiece
with my previous command that i showed
you right over here so i can say ufw
deny protocol tcp
from any to uh
from any to any port and then specify
3306 here hit enter the rules are going
to be updated so we can deny all
connections to our sql database which is
hugely important that's why you have
open databases running and available to
be accessed publicly on show then they
can simply be exposed so this is one of
the things you must do on your firewall
all right so getting back to ip
addresses again it's very very simple so
if i want to allow incoming connections
from a particular ip address i can
simply type in ufw
allow and i type in uh the ips so allow
from
192.168.1.1 which is my gateway or
access point iep address which is
important because if i don't allow
incoming connections from it
i essentially won't be able to to get
any internet access so i'm going to hit
allow which is important
and and that's very very important as i
mentioned when your firewall is active
because if you want to allow incoming
connections you need to specify what ip
or what ip subnet they may belonging to
so uh what an example i can give you
here is if you want to specify a
particular port uh for a particular ip
address for example i i only want the ip
address
192.168.1.103 to access ssh i can type
in the following so i say sudo ufw
allow from 192.168.1.103
to any port
to any port 22. so this will only allow
uh this particular ip address to access
the as this the ssh service i'm going to
enter it's going to say rules are
updated now if you're wondering what uh
the ip address 192.168.1.103
is my windows operating system and i
usually connect to my cali operating
system to it remotely via uh via putty
all right so that is a good rule to have
uh when talking about subnets it's very
very simple again so sudo ufw uh allow
from and we specify the subnet range
here 182.968.1.1
uh and 24 but i don't want to do that
because i only want particular ip
addresses
uh to essentially uh to be allowed in
regards to incoming connections so i'm
gonna i'm not gonna hit enter but that
is how to specify a particular subnet
you can also disable or deny a
particular connections
all right so
we have already talked about denying uh
access and again it is all in regards to
what you want to do in regards to the ip
so what i can say for example if i
wanted to allow a particular subnet
to access the mysql database i can say
for example
sudo
ufw
allow
from
192.68.1.1.1
and 24 and to any
any port
i can say any port
3306 of course that is a very stupid
thing to do so i'll just keep it to port
22 with this which is ssh so all of my
computers in my subnet should be able to
access this computer via the ssh port
only i'm going to hit enter and it's
going to tell me rule change after
normalization because we already had it
active so it is changed and updated the
rule
all right so let's talk about deleting
rules because that is essentially as far
as it will go in regards to allowing in
denying rules to uh incoming and
outgoing connections
to and from your firewall so we've
looked at allowing and denying ports
services and ip addresses let's talk
about deleting particular rules so now
that we've set our rules we can
essentially enable the firewall now so
i'm going to say sudo
sorry about that sudo
sudo enable and we type in uh sudo ufw
enable sorry about that
ufw enable i was getting a bit confused
there with ip tables you have w enable
and that's going to enable the firewall
excellent so now we can check the status
all right so the status as i mentioned
is very very simple to check uh which by
the way is going to include the number
status so the default status is sudo ufw
status
gonna hit enter and it's gonna give you
the current status of the firewall all
right so
tcp
is going to be allowed which is port 22
which is as it is going to be allowed
which is incoming
it's going to allow
tcp our weight we have port 80 deny
allow for for it again so incoming
outgoing uh the same goes for what we
had set for um
the rule set for both
uh http and https we had set our ftp
rule set here we'd set our mysql
database rule set here to deny
again we had set it
via tcp remember it's very important to
specify the protocol
uh we then have again we set the rules
to now a particular iep address remember
from here they were all from anywhere or
any particular source
so allow all connections coming from
my access point uh allow all ssh
connections in coming from this
particular ip
allow any incoming ssh connections from
any particular ip in this subnet which i
set incorrectly it should have been one
not zero that's my primary
uh access point that is sitting outside
of my office
and then we have all the all these
settings for uh for the ipv
ipv6 protocol so that is how to check
the status now you want to display a bit
more information we use the verbose
command
verbose over here and i'll give you a
bit more information and this is
primarily what i like using
so this is the status that i like using
the verbose status because it tells you
the status is active logging is on on
low
the default policies are to deny
incoming and allow outgoing as i
mentioned
and now we have for
for port 22 under the protocol tcp we
want to allow incoming connections we
want to allow incoming connections there
which we is not clever but anyway we had
set it to any computer on this subnet so
that makes sense
we want to deny incoming http
connections we want to allow then
incoming http connection and that's
because i was actually showing you that
we can actually disable it so
i can say ufw
we can say d9
for 80
and it's going to update it and we hit
enter and there we are so now it's it's
where we're simply denying the rules
here which is great all right so deny
deny for both port 80 which is http uh
for https we are also denying and that's
simply giving you the the action so
we're denying or allowing in connections
and the only ones being allowed inside
are going to be for the ssh port right
over here and right over here which are
going to simply be allowing particular
ip addresses
and the entire subnet and all ip
addresses from the connection now you
might want to change this if you want to
only specify a particular subnet
but that's simply how to check the
verbose status now if you want to look
at the numbered status which is
important because you might want to
delete a particular rule you do that by
typing sudo ufw status numbered
[Applause]
status numbered
like so and we hit enter and that is
going to number all of the rules that
you had set which is very important if
you want to delete a particular rule all
right so let's take a look at how to
delete a particular rule so if i wanted
to delete um
i want to delete
rule 1 and 2 i can do that so i can type
in sudo ufw delete
and i simply type in one for example and
that is going to ask me do i want to
delete this particular rule i'm going to
hit yes and then i'm going to i want to
delete rule 2 as well and yes and if we
check the these these status the verbose
status here we can see yes now we are
talking now we have uh we we have
correctly set up our our firewall here
so it's going to allow
uh allow in connections we can also get
rid of that one as well so we're going
to simply display the status here the
number status so let's get rid of 1 as
well
1 here yes we want to get rid of that
and we showed the status once more
we can see that yes we are denying all
connections all http connections all
https connections and we also set this
rule which is a duplicate rule of both
these two so i'm showing you how to do
it really shortly uh we are denying ftp
we are denying uh mysql access
via tcp and also the the port whether it
be on tcp or udp irregardless the only
ones we're allowing inside are going to
be connections coming from this
particular ip which is the access point
and this particular ip which is my
windows operating system and that is
going to be going to be allowed on port
22
uh and the entire subnet is going to be
allowed on port 22 which is really
redundant because i should have just
gotten rid of this one right over here
but regardless that is how to delete uh
the particular rules and if you want to
reset it again resetting it is very very
simple to take it back to the defaults
that if is if you have messed up your
rule set and you want to just start over
fresh so sudo
ufw
reset and we hit enter it's going to ask
you yes
and remember the firewall is still
active so if i just check the status
it's going to tell us that it is
inactive that's because we reset it so
uh if we we uh we enable it so ufw
enable
and uh we'll then check the status right
now we have or we don't have any rule
set so that is how to use ufw or the
uncomplicated firewall to allow incoming
and outgoing connections to ports
from ip addresses particular ip
addresses their services how to delete
particular rules and how to monitor the
current rules that you have set up so
that is pretty much all you need to know
in regards to getting started and and
fully utilizing ufw you know in in
regards to configuring a particular
operating system or a server if that's
what you're working with so
in this video i'll be showing you how to
clear your tracks on linux operating
systems with a variety of tools all
right so why is this important now if
you're a penetration tester you probably
already know why this is important well
covering tracks or clearing your tracks
is the final stage of penetration of the
penetration testing process so just
before you start report writing and that
video is on its way by the way so do
stay tuned for that so clearing your
tracks essentially involves clearing or
wiping all the activity of an attacker
or you being the attacker that is so as
to avoid any detection by incident
response teams or forensic teams all
right so it is vitally important in the
penetration testing life cycle
and of course if you look at it from a
defensive point of view it can really
test incident handlers and the blue team
in their ability to discover an attacker
in in the system whether they do have an
intrusion detection detection system or
not and of course from the perspective
of the forensics teams it can also test
them in uh sort of analyzing their skill
and finding what the attack the attacker
may have left behind in regards to logs
uh files or backdoors that they may have
left running any user accounts that they
were using etc so this is usually or
commonly the biggest mistake vector that
an attacker makes all right or that is
associated with with attackers and it's
something that has been ignored over the
years which is really really weird
because if you read or pick up any
penetration testing book
when they essentially explain the
penetration testing
cycle or the stages of penetration
testing uh clearing your tracks is one
of them just before you actually write
up your report and of course if you're
an attacker this is the final stage of
uh of your attack and of course leaving
some persistence behind but that's
another video for another time
so
it's it's very very sad to see that this
is not taken into consideration i'm not
talking about this from an attacker's
perspective but also from a blue team
perspective where uh this is something
that is very easy for them because
attackers are very very sloppy they they
haven't taken it into consideration so
it's really good to essentially
understand how this is done and how it
can be
and how it can be analyzed from both
perspectives from a red team and a blue
team perspective so
uh this is usually as i've said the
biggest mistake of an attacker and this
is where the professional attackers are
sorted out from the amateurs so if you
take a look at most of the biggest hacks
in the world over the last two years
most of the the detection has been made
really really easily from the malware
that they have left behind which they
didn't clear they should have cleared
but of course they were setting it up
for persistence as i said that's a video
for another time but again also masking
malware or backdoors is also a vital or
an important piece of uh of the forensic
or well not the forensic the post
exploitation
all right now when we talk about uh the
attacker's perspective uh he or she
usually needs to
evade detection if there is an intrusion
detection system therefore preventing
any incident response and then he or she
needs to clear the logs or back doors
that can be discovered by the forensics
team all right so what an attacker is
looking to do and should do is first of
all clear logs modify registries or
clear any of the registries that they
did create and lastly remove any files
or user accounts that they might have
been using all right now as i've said
for this particular video we'll be
focusing on linux i also want to make an
independent video for windows because it
is vitally important to understand how
to do so on both these operating systems
and also probably take a look at mac os
as that is also getting quite uh quite
popular especially for penetration
testers
so i'm going to be covering the
fundamentals and you can do a lot of
your own research i'll be covering the
tools that i've personally used before
and
really uh the last piece that i want to
actually tell you is clearing your
tracks will also depend on the
privileges that you have on the system
and whether or not you're remotely
attacking the system but for linux it is
quite universal
all right now i also have a little or a
quick tool that i'll be sharing with you
at the end of the video that is an a
forensics tool or an anti-forensics tool
for windows so you can definitely check
that out
i'll probably make another video of it
but for now let's focus on linux all
right so let's talk about the linux log
files which are the most important
aspects
uh of uh of persistence or activity that
is being logged on the linux operating
system or the linux kernel
all right so your the log files on any
linux system can be found on in the var
well actually let me just change
directory into that so cd var and it is
stored in the log directory right over
here so now that i'm in the directory i
can list all the files in here
and these are all the log files that
currently exist and of course if you
just read their name they're pretty
self-explanatory they have all they they
have they're all they all have their
various use cases and what data they are
essentially logging all right so for
example when talking about uh the
auth.log file this stores authentication
logs uh let's see if
let's see if we can find the kernel if
we can find yet there we are the
kernel.log file which essentially stores
all the kernel logs you then have the
mail server logs which is of course uh i
don't think we have a mail server here
but if we did you'd have the mail server
logs as well you then have the system
bootlog which is your boot your boot log
which again we don't have here for some
reason
we then have um
you have your http the httpd log which
essentially has logs for your web server
if you do have a web server
or a web server that being the apache
web server so again there are a lot of
log files here we're going to be
focusing on the auth log right of you
which essentially contains the
authentication logs and then we'll take
a look at the bash history file which is
very important as well we'll also take a
look at the shred file as well so
let's talk about the shred file and the
the the auth dot log file
all right so if i'm just to open up the
auth.log file here this essentially
stores all the uh the authentication
logs which are very very important for
to a forensics team uh to essentially
analyze what was happening to the system
what activities were carried out etc etc
all right so you can go ahead and
analyze all all of the files right over
here and get an idea of of essentially
uh what was going on and of course that
is uh
that deserves its own video in its own
right because that is more of a
forensics type of video
but for now we're looking to get rid of
this because remember if you're an
attacker you want to get rid of all of
these files so that uh they really
cannot build an idea of what was going
on on the system all right so let me
just exit out of this and as i said the
tool that is most recommended for any of
this getting erasing files erasing hard
drives is shred now if you haven't heard
of shred shred is essentially a tool
that allows you to delete uh or erase a
file permanently so it allows you to
delete files data permanently now many
of you might be confused with saying wow
why can't you just delete it well if you
delete a file
it can be recovered and i'll explain
this in a second so shred allows you to
delete files and data permanently and
prevents the recovery of that data
it does this because it over it
overwrites the file multiple times with
ones and zeros now when you
traditionally delete a file with your
graphical user interface or you simply
hit the delete a key on your keyboard
what's happening here
is your file isn't being deleted it is
simply marked as a space in which data
can be written to or data can be written
on top of therefore replacing the
previous data and of course this is
going to be dependent on how you use the
computer and that's why when you you see
these real amateurs are doing
questionable things on their computer
you know doing illegal stuff on the
computer
just delete the file without even
realizing that you aren't deleting it is
deleted for you the user but uh in the
back end the file still exists it's
simply marked that the sector is simply
marked as a as a space that should be
written onto us and when it's written
onto then the files are lost but you can
still perform a lot of data recovery
that's why you have an industry
dedicated to data recovery because of
how operating systems are and how they
uh they essentially mark spaces or data
that you won't delete it there's spaces
that can be overwritten all right so
that is the difference between keeping
files and maintaining uh the fact that
they cannot be written to
or overwritten that is
by other files and and
when you actually hit delete so when we
talk about a tool like shred shred is a
tool that i've used a lot of times
before for wiping or erasing hard drives
when i'm when i'm done with them when
i'm disposing them or when i'm selling
drives which is very very rare never
sell your drives
all right so shred comes pre-installed
in kali linux and i'm guessing in pretty
much all the other distributions so i'm
just going to clear this out and what
we're going to do is we're just going to
open up shred here with the help command
and the shred tool is quite
comprehensive and i'll try and explain
all the commands
all right so the shred command
essentially when you when you're writing
to a file or a particular drive it uh
it essentially overwrites the specified
files repeatedly and therefore making it
difficult or impossible for uh you know
hardware software or software recovery
to to get the data back all right so the
options or the parameters that you can
specify
with the shred tool are as follows you
have the f the f command which
essentially allows you to change
permissions to allow writing if needed
you have the n command which is the
iterations or essentially this allows
you to overwrite the amount of times you
want which is which is good the default
amount of times is three which is okay
but if you're really paranoid about you
know about your files and you really
want to get rid of them you can increase
the amount of times all the iterations
then have the size uh the size of the
number of bytes to shred you then have
the u command which is essentially
allows you to
uh to truncate uh it essentially
truncates and remove the files after
overwriting you then have the v command
over here which shows your progress over
both uh shows verbose information about
the progress you then have the x command
right over here which essentially
uh this what this does is again is it's
self-explanatory but this does not round
the files up to the next full block
uh we then have the z command which adds
the final overwrite with zeros to hide
shredding so it uh usually with uh
with software recovery tools they can
actually detect if there was shredding
done and this prevents that and you have
u the u command which essentially
removes the file after threading which
is what we're going to be taking a look
at as well
all right so let's take a look at the
command that we'll be using and i'll
explain what's going on
all right so we'll be using the vfzu
command which if we just look at the
arguments here we are going to be using
the v so verbose v
f z u so f we're going to force to
change the permissions if they exist so
if you don't have read and write
permissions is going to force it
uh so uh there we are so z uh we're
going to use the v f z u so then z is
going to be essentially add a final
override with zeros to hide the
shredding process which is good and we
are going to remove the file uh after or
after the overwriting process all right
so that is what is going on here so to
do that we simply type in shred
and after shred we type in our commands
or the combination of commands so
vfzu and the file which is auth.log and
i'm going to hit enter and there we are
all right so shred it's going to start
the shredding process right over here
and you can see shred uh authored logo
was renamed to zero zero zero et cetera
renamed renamed renamed all the way to
uh to the fact that the file was removed
or destroyed all right so that gets rid
of the auth.log file which essentially
gets rid of the authentication logs very
very simple you can take a look at all
the other logs and of course you might
want to get rid of all the other logs
that
that might have existed before or in the
fact in in regards to the services that
you might have used so for example if
you used mac changer which is quite rare
you might want to get rid of that log
file the kernel log file which is right
over here so
if we open it up
kernel.log
and there we are these are all the log
files in regards to the to the kernel so
again this is a file that you might want
to get rid of or you can simply edit
what you don't want in any of these log
files so as to to to sort of throw off
the forensic themes or off of your back
to essentially make it look really
really traditional all right so that is
how to clear your log files of course
you can use shred for deleting any other
file this is a video not it's not
designed to be uh to be about shred but
there you go you can use shred to erase
files uh permanently all right so do be
careful with it as well now let's talk
about bash history which is a video that
most of you guys requested me to to talk
about now bash history essentially keeps
a record of all the commands that were
executed by a user on the linux command
line
now this is very very important because
the uh the bash history is a is a file
that is kept uh
usually separated for each individual
user on the linux system so if you are
the root user you have your own bash
history file if there was a user called
alexis he will also have his own bash
history file you get the idea so
the directory in which it is stored in
is in the home user the user that being
the user that you are using
and the file is the dot bash history
file
all right so i'll get to that in a
second so if there was a user
let me just go back into the root
directory and this is where it is stored
so if you do have a user it is stored in
the
home and the username so this is where
you put in the username and it is stored
under the bash history file right over
here
all right
so that is if you are using a particular
use on the system which is quite obvious
but if you do have root privileges then
it's also important but you essentially
want to get rid of all the bash history
because this will essentially give
forensics teams a list of all of what
you did on that system
all right so let me actually show you
how this can be analyzed so i'm just
going to open up nano here and since i'm
in the root directory i think i should
have the there we are the bash history
file
uh now i personally have a lot of
important information in there so i'm
going to simply show you how to get to
wipe it all right now wiping it you can
also use shred if you want to but i
don't recommend doing that because again
you're really starting to
you're helping the forensic team build
uh an idea of what type of attacker
they're dealing with so i would
recommend keeping things as normal as
possible
all right so if you you can also use the
null redirect to clear the file which is
what i'm going to do so you can
essentially use the null redirect as
follows so
bash history
and uh as on once i hit enter it will
essentially clear the file because i'm
using null redirect so it's essentially
clearing the entire file so
bash history let me open up the file
sorry
nano
uh and um
bash
history as follows and there we are so
it's empty now you might be wondering
well it is empty but did it contain
anything well if we start using the
terminal here which uh am i currently
using this so i'm using terminator
uh yeah there we are so i was using a
material session i was just working on a
few hack the box videos which will also
be coming out so don't worry about that
so if i was to do your sudo apt get
update
there is a command that i did run and we
try and open up the bash history file
right over here and we'll let we let
that running and that is in my uh
terminator session all right so let's
open it up one more time and uh for some
reason it isn't showing up well we have
to wait for the command to execute so
uh let me just wait for that to execute
so i'll get back to you when this is
done
alrighty i'm back i've essentially just
ran a few commands i was just doing a
bit of metasploit work i was using
messer venom all that good stuff because
i really wanted to show you how much
information the bash history file can
uh can actually reveal so let me just
open it up one more time here
and my terminal always lags out when i
resume a video which is really weird
something to do with my processor let me
know if you guys know what's going on
here alright so bash
bash history like so when we hit enter
and there you are so you can see that i
was doing uh some very interesting
things here
so i went to my desktop i created a
payload the message venom i copied the
uh the payload to my apache directory i
restarted apache
uh looks like i removed a motility
installation i also removed an
index.html file
uh well i cleared the terminal i'm
actually missed i misspelled so yeah
this reveals a lot of information about
what the attacker was doing or what a
particular user was doing on the system
so
so there you go and it'll also tell you
that your attacker has really bad typing
skills and really makes a lot of
spelling mistakes so yeah you can pretty
much get an idea of what exactly is
going on here
all right so that's pretty much going to
be it for this video guys thank you so
much for watching
if you have any questions or suggestions
let me know in the comment section on my
social networks on my website and i'll
be seeing you in the next video peace
guys
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to be
taking a look at ssh brute force
protection with fail to ban now before
we actually get started with setting it
up let's get a bit of an understanding
as to what this tool is and how we can
use it
for ssh brute force protection all right
so what is fail to ban filter ban is an
intrusion prevention framework that's
written in python
and that protects linux systems and
servers from brute force attacks now
these are not limited to ssh but the
scope of this video is going to be based
around ssh as the primary service that
is going to be protected uh you know
from brute force attacks
all right so it allows you to monitor
the strength and the frequency of
attacks and then from that you can sort
of create various jails that you can use
and you can sort of customize your the
strength of the defense you want to set
up based on the attacks you're getting
and of course fail to ban can be set up
to block ip addresses automatically
based on specific parameters more of
which i'll explain as we move along all
right so the great thing about fail the
ban is that it automates the process of
protecting your server
or your ssh from brute force attacks
alright so
let's get started all right now that we
have an understanding of what fail to
ban is and how we can use it to protect
our servers you know from brute force
attacks on ssh
let's take a look at the infrastructure
we'll be using in this video
so for the purpose of this video i've
just set up a quick
a quick server here with linux and i'll
just copy the ip address it's just a
simple ubuntu server and they'll
demonstrate how powerful filthban
actually is so i'll just open up a
terminal here and we can try and log
into this server right now i haven't set
any any other user account so we'll be
logging as the root user
and let me just enter the password here
and that should log us in immediately so
the first thing i want to do is i want
to update
the packages because we do need to
install fail to ban all right so i'm
just going to say upgrade update here
and we do need to run sudo there because
we're already using the root user but in
any case
let's just update the packages here or
the repositories sorry not our packages
now filter ban is completely free to use
and you know you can install it through
most of your popular package managers in
our case we're just going to use the
aptitude package manager so as a apt-get
install and we're going to say fail to
pan and we hit enter
and that is going to prompt us to
download about 18.7 megabytes and we're
just gonna let that install
uh this shouldn't take uh too much time
and we can see we do have a sim link
created here that's very important for
the filter band service so one of the
first things we need to do is we need to
ensure that we have enabled fail to ban
to run on on system startup so in the
event you do reboot your server uh you
need to make sure that filter ban you
know runs
directly on the startup or during the
startup so to do this we'll use a
systemd so system control and we'll say
um enable
uh of course we're gonna say fill to ban
and the service is actually called fail
to ban dot service so we're gonna hit
enter
and as you can see it's gonna say
synchronizing the state of the
filterband service with the csv
service script uh so irregardless of
whether we used systemd
so
what we can do now is we can start
taking a look at the configuration files
right now the configuration files
for failed ban are going to be found in
the etsy uh they're in the etsy
directory so we can say um let's just
list all the files etsy
fail to ban and we hit enter and let's
take a look at these configuration files
so the most important one that you want
you want to be familiar with is are
going to be the jail dot conf file and
the filterband.com file or the
filterband.com file is a file we'll not
be taking a look at
uh in this video but we're taking a look
at the actual jail.configuration file
now uh uh if a fairly frequent or common
term that you'll be hearing uh you know
that will hear being mentioned when
talking about fail the ban is the use of
jails all right so what is a jail in
filter ban well a jail is essentially a
configuration file
that you know contains filters or
arguments that protect your system or a
particular service now by default all
your jails for particular services are
going to be in the jail.conf file
alright so if i just get the contents or
let's actually view the entire file we
can say um
let me move into the directory so it's
much easier for us to work there
so we can say less and we say
jail
jl.conf and we hit enter uh you can
pretty much see that first of all it
tells you that uh this is not the uh the
appropriate way of actually creating or
modifying the already preset jails the
reason being is this we should actually
create another jail.configuration file
uh with the local extension so you can
see in most of the cases you should not
modify this file but provide
customizations in the jail.loc of the
gel.local file or you can create
separate.con files under the jl.d
directory something we're not going to
be doing because the gel.local file is
pretty much the best way of going about
it so what you can do is you can copy
this file and you know you can make a
copy of it however the second copy is
going to be called jail.local
in within this uh it has various jails
that protect various services now the
first one you can see
is uh going to be the sshd or the
openssh server service and it's going to
be enabled so a jail has already become
uh has already been configured for this
but you can see that there aren't any
protection uh configuration options that
have been set here
so for example the band time the default
band time for all jails on all services
irregardless of whether it's ssh or ftp
has been set to one hour now we can
pretty much customize this for uh
particular services which is what we
want to do so you can use this uh this
same configuration file uh and you can
copy it you know and use the local
extension and this will essentially set
up protection for all of those services
however in our case i want to
i want to actually create a new
jail.local file and the only service
that i'm going to be protecting or we're
going to be configuring is the
the the openssh server this sshd service
so again all we'll do is we will say um
we'll use them here and we'll say
jl.local
and we're going to hit enter now as you
already saw within the gel.configuration
file
we can essentially
we we can start working with these
services that we want to protect so
again we do this by specifying their
name so in our case the openssh server
is defined by the ssh daemon here so
we're going to say ssh daemon and then
after this we're going to start
providing the syntax now the first
important bit of syntax here is going to
be the enabled configuration or the
enabled option
this essentially you know
means whether this essentially controls
whether the jail is enabled uh or
disabled and the option here we can
specify is either true or false right
and of course that is self-explanatory
enabled means that the uh the jail or
the protection will be enabled or this
these particular configurations will be
enabled so for now let's just keep it at
false because i want to show you uh you
know a test brute force attack on the
server
uh before and after so what we'll do is
we'll just say false
and uh
after this we can then get started with
our configurations now let me just talk
about the various configurations that
exist here
uh so we pretty much need to specify the
service the port and the filter and the
log file that we'll be using now let me
explain that sounds like a mouthful but
it's really very simple to understand
all right so the first thing i want to
do is i want to say what's the pot the
port is going to be the ssh port right
so the ssh port here
and
after this we specify the filter that
we're looking for now the filter is
something very important right so let me
just open up a uh
i'll open up a new tab here and we can
try and authenticate to this server one
more time so i'll just say ssh root and
we'll just authenticate to this server
and the reason being is i want to show
you the log the log file that we're
talking about this is the auth.log file
now the auth.log file uh pretty much
stores all the authentication attempts
made to the server whether they they
were successful or whether they failed
and pretty much you can find this within
the let's just get the contents of the
file so you can find this within the log
directory under etsy and it's called the
author log file now when i talk about a
filter again a filter is very simple to
understand uh we'll just hit enter for
some reason we don't have
this file we're looking sorry this is in
the var directory my apologies i'm just
getting confused with the etsy directory
there so you can see that this gives you
um
it gives you a log here of all the
authentication attempts
and when i was talking about the actual
filter so if i say filter
this will essentially mean this is
essentially where you say fail to ban i
want you to look for this particular
filter in our case we're looking for the
ssh daemon or the sshd service here so
you can see
that for example if we take a look at
the first ssh
demon
log here we can see that this is the the
ssh server listening on port 22 and then
if we take a look at some authentication
attempts you can see we have an
authentication attempt here
that tells us accepted password for the
root user and the particular ip address
here
and this was made through ssh not a tty
session so if it can also tell you
whether the authentication is done
locally or remotely so that is the
filter we're looking for so we only want
to filter for ssh daemon or sshd
logs there so we then need to specify
the the location of the log file that
we're going to be using so say log path
is going to be equal to and we specify
the relative directory here so we're
going to say var
log
and auth.log here
and after this we can just hit enter and
we can now talk about the security
options right so the security options
are very simple the first or the first
of with of which is the most important
this is the max retry option and this is
where you specify the number of attempts
to be made before an ip address or a
user is banned all right so to do this
we say max retry
max retry and that's going to be equal
to in our case we'll just say three so
the number of uh so we say the number of
attempts to be made before a band is
going to be equal to three so if you
enter
you know an incorrect password three
times that's that you're going to be
banned right
now we then have the band time right so
the band time
is again self explanatory this is the
number of seconds an ip address will be
banned for now typically you can set it
to an hour which is uh is primarily
going to be uh you know 3600 seconds or
you can uh you can specify a day which
is a very good option that many system
administrators set so again
we can just calculate this so 60 times
60 um that pretty much gives us what
we're looking for that's 3600 multiplied
by 24 hours that's going to be 86 400 so
we can say 86
400 and that's typically going to block
uh any ip addresses that have incorrect
authentications more than three or uh
three incorrect authentications for
entire day
right so what we can do is we'll just
set it to 3600 or we can set it to 60
seconds whatever you feel is appropriate
for your server based on the attacks
you've been getting or you can set a
generic one if you're monitoring your
server and seeing how many attacks
you're typically getting which i'll show
you how to monitor
you can then ignore ip addresses so you
can whitelist ip addresses
so again that's done by specifying
ignore ip and then within this you can
then specify any ip addresses that you
may want to white if you're a system
administrator it may be wise to enter
your ip address here
um so you can do that and i think
we can also specify uh i've specified
band time what about find time so the
amount of time between failed uh login
attempts
we can you can just say find time
or we can actually leave that out
because we really don't need that uh
these are these options are pretty
pretty good um so we can save
this file
and we
we
ensured that this jail was disabled and
the reason being is i want to show you
what you know typical field
authentication looks like
so what i'll do is um let me just exit
from here and i'll just
ssh into this and i'll enter incorrect
passwords now typically the the
the max amount of times you're allowed
to authenticate incorrectly is three
times that's the default one but i'll
explain something interesting here so
for example
uh actually before i do this because i
do want to block my ip address because
it is going to connect to it remotely
let's see if we can actually use proxy
chains here so let me just open up this
in part os and i'll expand this
uh or we can actually use anon surf so
let me just use anon surf instead of
using proxy chain so we'll just start
this
yes go ahead
and the reason being is i don't want to
actually expose my real ip address here
because when i'll be showing you the ip
addresses that were blocked uh this will
come into play so what i'll do is i'll
just wait for announcers and on surf to
start before we authenticate to the
server and i'll show you what happens
here
so remember the jail has is currently
disabled and ssh protection is is
currently not active with fail to ban
all right so we are currently uh
anonymized here so what we'll do is
we'll say ssh
root at
and we'll hit enter
and we'll say yes we want to accept the
fingerprint and we'll enter incorrect
password so i can just say password
and again that will be incorrect
permission denied
password will hit enter
another incorrect password attempt for
authentication attempt hit enter one
more time
and there we are you can see so it gives
you three attempts by default and then
after which you're told permission
denied let's try this one more time so
we're we're sort of exceeding the amount
of attempts but remember we haven't
enabled the fail to ban jail so we can
still try authenticating incorrectly
say password
and
password let's try it a few more times
and there we are we can still see that
after three unsuccessful attempts
uh it uh it it essentially disconnects
the the connection what i'll do is we'll
just wait for we'll just close this and
uh let's restart the service before we
actually get started so again uh before
after writing any changes to your uh to
your jail configuration file
uh you essentially need to restart the
the filterband service so we say system
control
sorry system
system control and we say restart
uh we'll say fill a two band service and
we
hit enter and that's going to restart it
so now that we've tested that this uh
that we you know we currently do not
have any brute force protection here uh
what we can do is we can modify this
file and we can say uh set this to true
so now we're going to activate the
protection so we're gonna say true
and we're going to write changes and
exit and we'll restart the filter band
service and let me just check the status
here
[Music]
sorry that is incorrect
we'll just change this to status and we
can see it's active and running this is
very important because
if you do want to actually check if
you're having any issues with your
syntax or any of the filters you've set
up for your particular jail in the jail
configuration file
this is where you can actually check if
there are any issues and you also have
the log here so you can see stopped
start started and we're ready again so
we can now get started and we can test
it one more time so what i'll do is i'll
use the same ip address here
and what we'll do is we'll just say ssh
root act
and for some reason we're being told the
connection was closed by remote host
so let's try a different ip here so uh
let's see if we can let's check the
um
the status of of the tor service
and we remember we need uh
do we have tor running we currently have
door running i believe but i think we
still need to disable the anon surf here
we can just stop it
uh so we'll say stop and we'll wait for
this to stop
and i think we can just use proxy chains
now that would be much better
uh instead of using anon surf
although i should have done that before
but i just wanted to explain a point
here so
all anonymous mode has been stopped and
we'll just start store
uh actually yeah we can we can do we'll
start it and uh now let's use proxy
chains i'll say proxy chains
ssh um i'll say root at and we'll paste
the ip in here
all right so it'll ask us for the
password and i'll just enter an
incorrect password late enter
and uh lend an incorrect password again
remember we have said we have set the
options in the gel configuration file to
three so again it will just uh it will
block the user for the first three
attempts obviously
uh we aren't getting a response we can
also try brute forcing with hydra
which is also another option so let's
try this out so we'll say
hydra
uh l uh we'll say root
and the password list is gonna be user
uh share
and we're gonna say word lists and we'll
use some of the meta split word lists
here
uh let's see which ones we have
do we have any ssh ones
nothing much
we can use the common roots let's try
that we can just use any the the bottom
line is i just want to show you
what this would look like
so we're looking for ssh
and we specify the ip address here
let's get rid of any other sessions that
i had and let's have some verbose output
and let enter
and you can see it tells us that could
not connect to
to this particular ip
connection refused what i'll do is uh we
can you can see that after the third
failed attempt
we can see that we get no response and
that actually proves that it's working
however i'll i'll actually show you how
you can check this so if we just
terminate this and we go back in on to
our server we can view the logs and the
failed authentication attempts and the
blocked ips
uh by taking a look at the filter ban
client here so i can hit enter and then
after this we want to display the status
right so if i hit status and we hit
enter this will give you the number of
jails that you have and as you can see
we have only one gel and that is the ssh
daemon so we want to check the status of
the ssh
daemon or this is ssh server as the
openssh server
uh jail and we hit enter all right and
you can see that the status for the jail
is as follows so the filter is
the currently failed is zero the total
amount of failed authentication attempts
is six
uh you then have the file list which is
uh the authentication log that is going
through uh it's banned three ip
addresses so the total amount of band
ips is three you have the band ips that
i think we used with unknown surf
and also with store and my ip address
here which for some reason it blocked i
think that's because i disabled
um i think i disabled announcers and
pareto's using my ip in any case
so what we can do now is we can go back
into parrot and um
if we take a look at hydra we can see
that we have a few issues here so let's
test this one more time by running anal
surf
again and then we'll try and run hydra
with that so that we have a new ip we
can work with
because it looked through the filter
bank line that it did work um
so and when i'd run
i'd run proxy chains with hydra here
uh because actually didn't run proxy
chains directly so if i try and do that
right now we can actually do it here so
we can save proxy chains
um
we'll wait for this to connect first so
we're currently on the announcer tunnel
so we can just run it through this so we
hit enter
there's going to test if possible
authentication is supported and you can
see it is working and
immediately we're getting a few
connection errors so
it's going to try connecting again but
what we can do is um
[Music]
we can say sudo
we'll say
proxy chains and we'll run this with
hydra right and i'll enter my password
here
so we can see that it's currently
supported
and
immediately we get uh authentication
errors to the server so that's working
fine let's take a look at the filter
bank client one more time so again i'll
just clear that out and we can run the
fill to burn client and check the number
of failed authentication attempts again
and now you can see that again the
amount of failed authentication attempts
has moved up to 38
and the currently the the total amount
of band ip addresses are as follows so
we have various ones that we had uh that
we have uh that we got with anon surf
and proxy chains to uh
to a certain extent so
uh that's pretty much how to view
um
this is pretty much how to view all the
failed authentication attempts and the
blocked ips which you can then use to
build a geographical model of where most
of the attacks are coming from even
though they may be coming from a botnet
uh so again that's how to use feldeban
uh so again if you want to disable a
particular jail uh we can just check
this out here
uh fill the ban and you can then modify
the local configuration file so we can
use fim and we say jail dot local
and we enter so if i'm working with the
ssh daemon i can just disable this
to false here and that will disable the
protection
and if i just run and exit and we can
try and restart this service so i can
say
system control
we can say restart
oops sorry
restart let me just reduce the font size
here and we'll say fill to ban
service and we'll hit enter
and there we are
all right uh let's take a look at
whether we can actually log in now
so i'll say exit
and this is through my local ip i'm not
going to use proxy chains
um so i'll say
ssh will actually just ssh without proxy
change ssh
root at this particular ip and you can
see it now works perfectly fine so if i
hit another
uh you know some other incorrect
passwords we are now able to
at least get authentication attempts
across the line uh but yeah that's
pretty much all that i wanted to show
you guys how to do um you know with
failed by how to use fill the band you
know to protect to protect your server
from uh ssh brute forces uh let me know
if you have any questions or suggestions
and i'll be seeing you in the next video